I'm on the eve of an epic weekend.
The fights we come to live to break this
shit down.
The Quito kid.
What's up,
bro?
What is that?
That shirt reminds me of something and
I'm trying to figure out what it reminds
me of some Japanese in the summer.
That was summer.
It's so fucking summer.
This isn't the yellow and I gave you
the.
The yellow one is so summer.
It's a fighter and the kid shirt with
Brian.
This is such a perfect shirt for Brian.
All of his pictures should be him
leaping pretending to be a ballerina for
ells.
The endless summer.
Yeah.
Similar.
Yeah,
very similar.
So it's a collab with roots of faith
where we got the idea.
That's this summer.
What's your summer?
Every day in Venice Beach,
California.
Unless you're a bum.
It was summer though.
That's true.
Hottest fucking a nice Tan.
Nice Tan.
That's true,
Bro.
You don't.
I'll tell you right now.
You don't wanna be on Venice beach
during July.
Fourth at night.
Was that do I even posted?
It was like the purge.
I was scared.
I might get in the car,
fucking google guns,
fireworks,
smoke.
I was like,
holy garments.
You.
Oh yeah,
street.
We'll just shoot up in the air to those.
But they're not like shooting towards
the ocean,
you know?
It was like a rap video.
I'd fucking flew.
I was stressed to.
I've been to Venice a few times and
every time I'm there I'm like,
why would anybody live here?
Well,
you live in the middle of nowhere.
Where secluded.
I know that's your style.
I like to be able to be more in the
middle of nowhere.
I want to go straight to the woods off
with you.
I liked it.
Your kids might not.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't think they'd like Venice either.
There's a comfortable medium.
There's parts of Venice like what?
Like you on that,
but Kenny was just crowded as well.
There's a nice little restaurants there.
It's a good spot to drop.
Bank gets neat and true,
but she's packed and feel happy that you
don't live there.
Well,
no.
See I live like away from the word
slower.
Like del Rey,
right on the beat.
That's nice.
If you have like a Prius,
it's a good place to live because the
parking spots were all like Prius sized.
That's why I can walk and that's why I
said because I like to be able to walk
everywhere to the genome.
Everything.
Ride my bike.
Run on the beach.
You would run on the beach.
We're here at Sun.
No,
not.
I could run hills though.
It's cool
to.
He like to run the beach.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I can't be a better path,
man.
You just like being.
You just don't.
You don't want neighbors.
Well,
this overpopulation,
it's not that I don't like neighbors.
There's a very clear overpopulation
problem.
Like A.
I told you I went to yellowstone a
couple of weeks ago and one of the
things that I got out of that about
being in Montana and Wyoming is that
like you feel more at peace when you
look at nature and there's less people.
It's more relaxing.
One hundred percent.
There's not the hustle.
I think you need both though,
but there's a reason why there's no one
out there.
You're in the middle of fucking nowhere.
Your neighbors were the grizzly bear.
That's part of the reason.
The big reason.
The winter,
the winter comes.
You can keep that and you like that shit
out of mind.
It just stay inside.
Make a fire.
Your kids are going to be miserable.
You Muslim out,
maybe.
Maybe not.
Maybe they enjoy it,
so I saw a bunch of happy kids out there
right now.
If you move them out for good,
they have cell phones out there.
They have internet.
Very few differences culturally,
friends to have each other.
Oh,
there's plenty of pizza there.
You just said there's 35,000 people in
the town.
A lot.
That's a lot.
That's more than I thought.
How many people are in Venice?
At least a million to 20 million Venice.
Winning the size of a football field.
There's a million people live in their.
You know,
Abot.
Kenny just got a,
which is not a good thing,
but per square foot.
It's the most expensive street in Los
Angeles.
Just beat out rodale drive.
Oh God.
I know that.
It's beyond me.
How crazy is that?
It makes sense.
I've seen real estate in Venice.
It's insane.
I saw a house that was for sale.
It was $14,000,000 and it was a house
just to fucking house.
I mean it's Venice man.
It's to great restaurants,
friendly people,
Venice foot guys walking around.
Not not,
you know,
know when,
when I first moved there like way way
back in the day I used to visit them
there and I'd be like,
what in the fuck are you doing here man?
Like why here?
Well,
but when you first moved here,
were you Hollywood?
No,
I first lived in Burbank at one of those
Oakwood apartments and then I moved to
North Hollywood.
My car got broken into and then I moved
to Encino.
I mean North Hollywood.
That's a hustle too.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
You've been in done that like city life.
It's just too many people.
I agree.
It's a lot of people.
I just don't think it's healthy.
I think when mean I think you can deal
with it,
but I think there's,
there's an effect of too many people on
you all the time around you all the
time.
Buzz,
buzz,
all that data coming in.
I think it affects your thinking
process.
I think it makes you accelerate,
like they did a study with a put cameras
up and cities and they monitored the
amount of footsteps that people take per
minute and through the amount of
footsteps that people take per minute
and the amount of syllables.
As people speak per minute,
they can accurately determine how many
people live in that city.
Damn.
Yeah.
Like down to like a thousand,
you know,
they can tell you like,
what's one?
This is 2 million people.
This is a city of 5 million people.
This is a city of 6 million people.
They could tell by watching people walk
and by listening to people talk because
when there's too many people around,
everything run ramps up and accelerates.
Like when I was in Wyoming,
you know,
but driving around yellowstone,
it's so peaceful and relaxed and I came
back here and the moment we started
driving home I started feeling it.
I was like,
everyone's driving faster.
Everyone's cutting everybody
off.
And I'm like,
this is a direct response to the
overpopulation issue.
Is it overpopulation or is it the
hustle?
You know,
it's this,
the American mindset,
the hustle where you got to make money,
get a job,
provide.
If it was Sunday,
they weren't hustling to go make money
to get.
We're just cutting each other off.
It's a bummer.
And plus people don't really talk to
each other anymore.
There's not a lot of that.
Yeah,
well I think it's.
People aren't as valuable.
It's like if you have.
Do you ever see those things about Pablo
Escobar that he's to light fires with
like a million dollars?
Oh yeah.
Because he had so much fucking money.
A million dollars wasn't shit to him.
The same thing happens with people.
If you live in a place that has 30
million people stuffed into it,
if you don't value people the way you
value people,
if you're in a small town,
that makes sense,
but you also don't know him either
because you can't.
Yeah,
you can't.
There's no way.
No,
there's no way you'd know less people.
Which is weird.
Yeah.
Like I was talking to Jim Norton about
that because Jim Norton lives in this
big ass apartment building in New York
City and he said,
I don't know anybody.
He goes,
I've said hi once to a guy that's down
the hallway from me.
I don't know anybody else in the
building.
And I'm like,
how many people you think live in the
buildings?
Which thousand dollars?
Maybe more than 1000 people in the
building.
You can go out of your way though to
meet people.
Like last night I was at dinner at
Benihanas.
When's the last time I went to Bennett?
You kids like Benihanas?
Yeah,
we go to that place right there you go.
Talk to.
Don't dot my girl.
Her family.
Love it.
So we.
Yeah,
we went there and they sit with you sit
with random people,
right?
I'm trying to start a conversation
because we were having dinner together.
We're here for the long haul.
It's can show just not getting your
steak and then dipping out.
He's throwing shrimp at your face and
all that shit.
So I'm trying to talk to them and it was
exhausting man.
Because you would think they wanted
something from me,
you know what I'm saying?
Like was just like,
dude,
I literally just a friendly
conversation.
So it was weird because we were talking
about that last night.
I'm like,
no one really talks to each other
anymore and this is ridiculous.
When I was a kid I went to Benihanas and
someone paid for my meal,
paid for the table and I remember I word
whatever,
chicken and shrimp and I only had like
$20 in my pocket and I was so stressed
and I had to drink water and all this
stuff.
So someone paid for the meal and it was
like the best day of my life.
So I was like,
all right,
and I'm going to pay it forward.
So before we sat down,
I didn't know anyone.
I just gave the lady my card behind
them,
like I'm gonna cover the table.
She's like,
all right,
cool.
People on trying to.
People I'm trying to talk with.
It's their birthday,
right?
It's,
it's the,
the girl's birthday.
She starts in fucking peanut Pina
coladas all sorts of stuff,
man.
I'm like,
God dog.
I fucked
or and all sorts of shit.
It worked out though,
man.
That's it worked out.
But literally I was.
I didn't need anything from them.
I didn't want anything.
I just wanted to talk to them,
get to know him,
but I,
I guess I'm bigger dude.
I gotTa fucking fall asleep that to
whatever you'd like.
They were almost scare on a date.
They were on a date,
but it's still probably do is probably
trying to mack on his lady doesn't want
some better looking dude.
Law Muscular with all tattoos and shit
talking.
I was talking to him though.
Yeah,
but doesn't matter.
You eventually going to start target to
his woman.
He knows that's coming up.
The dude.
She's going to get all excited.
So now everyone wants to fuck your girl
down the nose.
Doesn't.
Family Environment.
People that they have motives.
They have ulterior motives.
There you go.
That's why you live in the fucking
mountains.
That's why I'm not starting up
conversations with random people at
Benihanas and you don't talk to me.
I do.
It just don't try hard.
Yeah,
I mean if someone says something I'll,
I'll talk.
We'll start talking,
but I'm like,
Hey,
look at you folks.
You guys going crazy over there with the
shrimp shrimp,
isn't it?
Hey,
do you like your with butter or garlic
or a shampoo
today,
man.
Yeah.
You're going to spend some time
together.
I get it.
You know what I'm saying?
Get the fuck out of Venice and broaden
your brain.
May Be men.
So a UFC 200 map.
There's not just UFC 200.
This.
This whole weekend is crazy because it's
Thursday night.
When was the last time there was a.
not just a world title fight on fight
pass,
but a world title fight between half El
Dos Anjos and Eddie Alvarez on fucking
Thursday night.
Thursday and it's only on fight pass.
What they should do if that.
If it's like a bad ass fight,
they should play that Friday or Saturday
for everyone.
Who's this card?
This is a good card for Thursday night.
God Damn.
You Got Nelson and Derrick Lewis.
Lewis is your job on that handsome
mother fuckers bad and I don't know this
gentlemen Billao Mohammed.
Do you know him?
Mohammed?
Remember the name is his nickname.
I don't remember the name.
Mohammed.
He motherfuckers what?
Your same pants fan.
Remember the name?
Get out of here,
dude.
Maybe he didn't pick that Joe Duffy back
on the fucking warpath against Mitch
Clark.
After dust employee a put a beating on
him and he did.
He got Mike pyle still doing the damn
thing.
He is this one.
How is he now?
Forty two.
40 three.
He's been doing it for ever Griffin's
coach before.
Forces fighting.
Legendary Jim fighter.
Legendary.
Like before he ever became a UFC guy.
Like everybody would talk about him
handling dudes.
I've heard crazy stories about him.
That's a tough guy.
How old is he?
Yeah,
at least 40,
41.
I would say 43.
Forty,
40,
40.
Besides Dan Henderson,
it's
a Dan Anderson that young Anderson and
him and probably the same age.
Anderson's 40 now.
Right,
but that the lighter weight,
it's tougher to maintain this long of a
career.
How many of these guys are pissed that
they weren't 46 years ago when t e,
r,
t was in full swing.
Those were the glory days.
The glory days that uh,
I don't know,
man,
I,
I mean I don't have flight path.
I don't want you on fight pass,
but if that dos Anjos and Eddie Alvarez
cards or that fight is a fight of the
night,
he got to play it on,
you know what I'm saying?
For the people just for notoriety as a,
as a world champion at 55,
I'm hearing Alvarez stories that he's
training like a fucking demon man.
Yeah.
I've heard,
I've,
I saw his interview that he did where he
said he did 150 rounds of sparring.
He doesn't believe in overtraining.
Excuse me sir.
It's not a debate.
It's science.
There's overtraining.
And he's like,
I think someone just made that up
because they didn't want to train that
date.
No,
that's not true.
The thing is,
you look at his last two fights.
We beat Pettis and he beat Melendez.
They're not,
it's not,
it's not that.
I mean,
granted he beat them.
It's not impressive.
He's not,
he's not like the dream Eddie Alvarez or
the belt or do knocking dudes out.
Like we don't see that Eddie Alvarez
yet,
and he said that's that that was his
plan,
but don't you think that a good part of
that is because of the competition that
he's facing?
I mean he just.
Sure he's facing the toughest guys in
the world.
So you change your fighting style?
No,
I just don't think he's capable of
fighting the same way against those
guys.
And winning.
I just don't think that you can go balls
out against pedis and just slug it out
with him the way he slugged it out with
some guys and other organizations.
True.
I mean,
he,
he went kind of,
he traded with Melendez but he has like
this clinching game now,
right?
Like it's this thing,
it's,
I can't match up for him.
Melendez got a lot of miles on them now
at this stage of his career as well,
you know,
Amanda's had some injuries and a bunch
of issues,
you know,
uh,
Alvis had those fucking wars with
Michael Chandler and you see how good
Michael Chandler looked the other day.
Yeah,
he's a,
he looked good and not just good because
the knockout punch.
But look good before that,
his footwork and movement,
everything looked good.
I'd love to see him in the UFC.
Yeah,
I would too.
Especially after that fight,
man,
that one punch knockout.
But I bet spike is taking care of them.
I bet they're giving them some good
money,
you know?
I mean,
should,
I mean I had a discussion with metro and
the other day and you know,
I discuss his financials but what he's
getting paid and chandler being the
champ [inaudible],
I'm sure he's getting that paper mitre
on almost got slept.
That was crazy.
He got wobbling just crazy and now he's
fighting.
I know that's not good.
And he was saying no,
he uh,
that's what I told him.
I said,
dude,
it's not smart.
And for what?
It's not like it's for a title.
If it's for a title.
Yeah.
Go get your money.
Become the champion.
Then rest,
he's fighting some Schmuck,
Somali Thompson guy who fought in the
UFC.
I don't think you want to fight in the
So he's going over there to beat this
guy.
But then he was like,
dude,
this so much.
They're paying pain,
to be honest.
It's easy.
You know,
he didn't say this,
but this is me gauging from his mantra.
It's easy work from where he's coming.
Super easy work.
Maybe he could probably be both guys in
the same night.
Right.
But if he did get concussed in that
fight,
it's hard to tell.
If he did 100 percent,
he has brain.
The brain suffered some sort of trauma.
You don't get wobbled and just like not.
I didn't feel anything yet.
Sat down to like his knees went,
his body sat down like it was a big
deal.
It's been that way.
Like when he fought Roy Nelson,
he was like,
I wasn't.
I wasn't even out.
And I was like,
Bro,
you got fucking rocked men maybe don't
remember it.
I'm telling you,
you have.
You had that brain trauma man.
When he sat down in the lights turn off
even for a second.
That counts.
Oh yeah,
100 percent.
The brain doesn't.
If it's a football head,
if it's punch kick,
it doesn't give a fuck.
It's the brain rattling around.
Some guys take comfort in the fact that
there were still conscious,
you know,
was like I was,
I didn't go out.
John Hendrick said,
same thing with wonderboy.
Yeah.
I didn't go out and I get that,
but if that ref isn't there,
your debt.
If this is the street,
you're dead.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's a tough call for him.
It's tough for Matt.
He was just like,
damn,
fighting this dude,
this dude this,
whether payment of that get your money
son.
It's tough because,
you know,
if he thinks he could stop it,
but then those are the fights that
sometimes you can get fucked up in
because you think it's an easy fight,
don't you think?
I mean there's,
there's times where you step in and say,
this is a fight that I can win.
Pretty easy.
True.
There's over the overconfidence,
but like rockhold and bisping for sure.
Rockhold was overconfident going into
that fight.
A little too relaxed.
Almost disdainful.
Just did not give a fuck.
Just Dot Murray.
I woke up my baby up.
Ooh.
I know.
He jumped out of my seat.
I was so scared.
Did you hear John Jones talk about that?
He had a great point.
Did you hear his interview?
What'd he say?
He goes,
because the media was like,
you know all this criticism,
get for Osp,
and he goes,
hold on home criticism.
Let's just go over this.
It was brilliant shit.
He goes,
what would you guys like to see?
I thought it was.
He goes,
I thought it was brilliant.
He was number six guys in the world,
South Ball.
They change it on four day notice,
some shit like that.
He was the explosive south pulse number
six in the world.
He goes,
you want me to to act and dance around
and get knocked out like a Anderson
Silva did or maybe you wanted me to go
in there and not respect them.
They get knocked out.
Luke rockhold w and what do you.
What do you guys want from me?
He was,
to me,
those guys will never be the same.
Like once they get knocked out like
that,
their legacy is over,
man.
He's like,
that won't be me.
I won't go down.
Go down as the greatest job.
You will never see me like that.
John Smarter in his approach,
he's definitely smarter and his approach
to fight,
he takes them very seriously.
Even if he's not 100 percent trained,
he doesn't fight reckless.
He fights,
he fights,
he takes chances,
but they're calculated chances.
He's improvisational in his,
in his movements.
But John's a bad motherfucker.
I mean his,
the reason why he's gotten into fights
and not trained very much and you know
and like been like fairly out of shape
is just his massive believer in what
he's been able to pull off inside the
octagon.
But you would think especially out what
it was he 22 years old when he won the
world title against Shogun.
You'll see 1:28 against A.
Yeah.
I can show you a new work.
So when he's there,
you,
if anyone's going to get overconfident
and do some bullshit,
it's gonna be Jon Jones.
Dude.
That the.
To me,
that's why it's pound for pound best
because look at the guys he's
fighting like DC.
He only has one last thing.
Not all the guys.
He's been that fight.
I don't care what anyone,
it wasn't that close.
NDC got taken down and kind of broke,
you know what I'm saying?
So for the guys John's beating and what
he's doing to them,
that's why,
to me,
he's pound for pound best.
WHO's mighty mouse by next
you're not going to.
Yeah.
Cool man.
Yeah,
no,
very cool.
There's no comp comp comparison.
And then what's next for John?
Probably gastrin rumble,
rumble.
He's just fucking monsters.
And Glover going to fight in a two O
two.
So perhaps a winter that.
And we saw how it went against.
He just dismantled glover.
Yeah.
So I'm just saying at the margin of
error for John and the way beating these
dudes,
that's why he's pound for pound number
one.
Greatest for me.
Well,
it's definitely an argument.
You know,
it's a subjective conversation.
I think when you look at the movements
and what mighty mouse was capable of
doing it inside the octagon.
I don't think anybody touches,
but look at level of competition.
Well,
it's also because he's eliminating so
much competition.
Like what could he did to Benevidez?
Benevidez is a world class fighter,
knocks him out in the first round.
Look what it does.
A Henry Cejudo Olympic gold medal.
Merck's.
I'm in the first round.
He had four fights.
Yeah,
I had more than that,
but.
But I saying in the UFC,
you know what I'm saying?
Like he's not,
he's not this established bad ass like
St John's Merkin Gusta Fin v tour,
clover,
clover trail,
like all these legends to good point.
That's a good point.
That's what I'm saying.
But that interview,
I,
it was,
it was so good man.
Because do you guys are gonna criticize
me for this?
He was in Rhonda.
He goes,
what do you.
They overlooked her opponent.
I'm not that guy.
I respect on this p.
well,
not only that,
I,
I didn't think that performance was bad
because first of all,
I have a lot of respect for Osp.
I think Osp is dangerous as fuck.
He hits really hard.
He's,
he's tough as shit.
And we saw that in that fight.
He broke his arm and the fourth round
didn't say God damn thing about it.
Yeah,
very explosive.
You can't fuck around with Osp and also
a you to,
you know this like,
it's when people that have never fought
before,
when you change from a,
from a traditional stance of south ball,
you're talking world of different.
The gap plans out the window,
especially with short notice is nuts.
Yeah.
No it is.
I mean,
and he did it because he realized that,
uh,
you know,
he was behind the eight ball already
going into that fight with all his
personal problems,
all the bullshit he had to take that
fight or he felt like he had to get sort
of like back in the fans.
Good graces.
I did not think it was a bad
performance.
A lot of people saying he looked
terrible.
I think he fought a really tough guy and
he fought smart.
Yeah.
Didn't really take that many chances for
really smart.
But also his mom that week got her leg
amputated.
Yup.
And you know what,
he didn't fight for what,
15 months before that.
I think it was 16,
so 16 months.
So he had that because if that same John
fight dc that night,
he had been in trouble,
you know,
maybe I don't know or maybe shows maybe
he gets another switch.
Well one of the things that he said when
I interviewed him after the fight is it
wasn't physical.
He was like,
physically I felt great.
He just like,
I just wasn't doing the things that I
wanted to do.
I wasn't,
I wasn't executing when I wanted to.
I was hesitating.
I think he was under a tremendous amount
of pressure.
I mean talking about a guy who came that
close to going to jail and a lot of
people felt like his,
his choices outside the ring,
we're going to lead to his demise.
And there was a lot of talk about that.
I mean just the amount of pressure that
he had to be under,
all the scrutiny,
all that.
That was a lot.
And then on top of that is also changed
his camp up quite a bit because you
started doing a lot of power lifting.
Did you hear him talk about that?
Yeah.
He said that it helped me.
It hurt him.
He's not,
he's not lifting anymore.
He doesn't.
Well,
I don't know if that's the answer,
but he hasn't lifted this camp.
Well,
you know,
some people believe that you should do
it and some people believe that you
shouldn't.
And some people believe that it's
something to do in between camps and
that what you really should be
concentrating on during campus.
Plyo.
Correct.
Yeah.
I think.
I think that's the.
And I think most experts agree like
outside of camp you build this,
this shell just you build your body as
healthy,
as big as it can get and then you go
into camp and you ditch that heavy lift
and all that stuff and just focus on
your cardio,
explosiveness,
footwork and stuff like that.
I had a really good conversation with
Diego about that once Diego Sanchez and
he was talking about how he treats it
dig.
It was very smart and as preparation and
that he takes time like in between the
safety as a fight,
like a.
he's fighting Miller this weekend.
Uh,
Lozan.
Oh,
that's fighting Lozan.
So he's fighting lawyers on this
weekend,
right?
Shit.
Did he just fight Jim Miller?
Yes.
He Won.
Right.
Beat Jim Miller did know.
I thought Jim Miller one who the fuck
one that find the jail sanction Miller
won by decision.
Really?
Maybe I just picked them to win,
man.
I'm trying to remember that fight.
I don't remember that fight at all and
neither.
What's that?
Yeah,
he did.
Boom.
Um,
so diego does all of his,
uh,
pre before the fight,
like you know,
before fight camp starts,
he does a lot of physical training.
You get this cardio very high.
He gets his weight lifting up.
He does all this different stuff,
but it doesn't do any sparring.
Who says drilling?
Does some drilling buddies mostly
concentrating on physical preparation,
like weightlifting,
Yoga,
all that jazz.
Then he gets in a peak state of physical
condition than he enters at camp.
Fully.
Fully trained,
like very,
very high rate of cardio.
Like he's not out of shape when he gets
into camp and then when he's in camp
then he concentrates on a skill sets.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
I think it's a smart way to do it
because Klitschko does us a complete
different sports.
The Klitschko brothers did it opposite.
They would do,
um,
the,
the first day we call it pre camp,
they just focus on skills and like their
jab,
the straight right,
the very basics for two or three weeks.
And then when they'd go into camp they'd
add and everything else.
But the first couple of weeks camp was
just the basics.
Very,
very basics.
But that's also,
he's in his forties.
Klitschko is right,
isn't it?
This is before the.
I don't know what he's doing now.
This was before?
Yeah.
How old is Klitschko?
Forty to 42.
I'd say 42.
But am I off on that?
Jamie heavily relies on Mexican
supplements.
Right?
The Russians have been known to dabble.
They've been known and he looks
fantastic.
He is bodied.
Hey,
did you see what Brock Lesnar said?
I'm white and I'm jack.
Get over it.
Yeah,
Dude.
And I liked them.
A lot of shit.
I actually liked.
I saw them like,
fuck you.
Hell yeah man.
Good free character.
He's a character.
He's a fucking character.
I would,
I would bet my entire life that he's
dabbled in some of that stuff.
That's just what they do.
How when he was over there for sure.
But he's been tested five times or was
tested five times in the last.
I heard about it.
True.
When,
when,
when he was clear to this Klitschko and
Tyson fury,
the guy on the right,
beat them 40 by 40 Dad Bod beat him dad
bod beat didn't beat the shit.
Um,
but me beat him.
He beat him,
fucked his head up before the fight.
That was the big deal.
Klitschko beat them in the rematch.
You think so?
Yeah.
It was such a boring fight.
It.
But uh,
what we're talking.
Oh,
with brock lesnar.
Did you hear what Mark said?
Mark goes,
they told me like three months ago,
hey man,
be ready for UFC 200 because,
uh,
we,
we were,
we might use you.
So make sure you're in shape.
And he's like,
they've never done that.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's like,
if you're bat shit crazy,
if you think brock's for weeks,
he was like,
y'all fight at $200,
are they going to test me?
I'm fine.
I'm clear.
Like it was obviously a plan,
you know what I'm saying?
And I'm not mad at it.
I get it for entertainment.
I can't wait to see the fight.
But you're batshit crazy if you don't
think this has been an ongoing thing and
they're just saving this fucking bat
card to save the.
I know it was an ongoing thing.
I can tell you.
I'll tell you everything that happened.
Okay.
There was a bunch of difficulties in
pulling this off.
Exactly.
A lot of it dealt with Vince and Vince
Mcmahon.
I say I call him vince because I don't
know him at all that your friends with
typed.
But boy vinny.
Um,
so there was a lot of work to pull this
off and it was touch and go touch and go
was they weren't sure whether or not
they're going to be able to pull it off.
So it was something that they tried to
get done.
But it took a long fucking time,
there was a lot of finagling and they've
had some,
some cooperation before,
like Rhonda,
she went over there and did some shows,
right?
Or did a show completely and um,
yeah,
but,
but that cross promotion can benefit
them.
So I think both,
both parties,
both parties.
So I think they wanted to work some
stuff out and figure out how to do it
right and whether or not there were
going to do it right and whether or not,
you know,
it's,
it ain't easy to pull those things off
when you've got a company like the wwe
and the UFC and they have egos.
Then you'll brock's,
they're freaking boy,
obviously he's their cash cow and then
he's the biggest draw of all time in the
UFC.
I get that.
I wonder what could happen if Mark Hunt
lays them out,
you know,
I mean,
and here's another thing,
like the reason why he stepped back,
one of the reasons you talked about when
he said he wasn't going to fight again
was a few years back,
right?
Three years ago he said he was concerned
about concussions.
Brock said that,
yeah,
it's more cut and he's fighting bitch.
You're fighting Mr. Concussion,
concussion.
Fucking captain over the ask right now.
I mean,
yeah,
I mean he's fighting one of the best
strikers to ever compete in MMA in the
division head or in the ve world.
He gave me a list.
He's number one.
He's.
He's certainly in the list mean he's
more skillful than you might have a guy
that hits harder than him physically
name someone in the heavyweight division
knocked out Roy Nelson.
Sir.
That's true.
I mean it's arguable.
Knocked out some monsters,
knocked out a lot of fucking people.
There's no doubt about it.
He hit very,
very hard.
That's why you look at brock and his
career.
I give him shit about the Dodo and all
that as far as an athlete and hit the
balls of doing what he's doing because
he doesn't have that many fights and
they just threw him to the fucking dogs.
You've married?
Started with heath herring.
He was frank mayor.
These randy couture,
far uber dream.
He fought the Uber and God dealt with.
He said he said the undertaker.
Yeah,
we ain't rehearsing this.
Here's a kick to the straight liver son.
He wasn't worried about being taken down
at all.
Didn't give a fuck.
Ubering looks so good enough.
Fine.
Oh my.
To me,
that's the hardest fighter ever to be in
the world.
Uber and I was scared.
I was still on the roster.
I'm like,
oh my God,
what if they call me with him?
What the fuck am I going to do the fuck
am I going to do?
It's not a good guy to fight.
Not that one.
Well,
it's that one.
That's almost.
I almost want to see what he could have
done.
You know,
if we were on old school testing.
Oh everyone getting fucked up.
We all go.
And sizzler.
I mean that's a,
that's a good picture right there where
you get to see what he looked like,
but that's.
We don't flex and right.
Yeah,
that's the picture.
Good.
Googling the back.
Just like,
God damn what in the fuck.
I was like,
okay,
how's he keeping that much mass on with
all that training,
you know?
Uh,
yeah,
I know exactly how Mexican supplements,
but it's fair.
You're crazy girl.
Think Brock was doing some sort of like,
it's a fair fight.
Well,
um,
there's a lot of things that are fair
about it skillfully.
I mean,
skill wise,
look,
overeem is a far superior MMA fighter,
far superior striking.
They're on there.
It's almost hard to put into context how
much better he states that are on the
same fucking planet.
Yeah.
I mean he's so much better.
And overeem knew it too because overeem
had seen brock struggle with Shane
and a scene Brockett beat up by Cain and
he knew what he was going to do to him.
I mean that was a confident juice to the
tits over.
He came in that mother fucker guns
blazing but also shit.
I mean he didn't just walk unfortunately
that bullshit.
College double leg.
Shoot that fucking shit.
Ask the Gita how that happened.
Like ahead and fucking shoot.
But I'll tell you what,
man,
I liked the way overeem fights now.
He's fighting smart as fuck now.
He moves around a lot,
picks his openings,
throws those leg kicks when he needs
them.
And when he lands bombs on
motherfuckers,
he's hurting people killing here.
Yes.
Very skillful,
very skillful.
The way for junior dos Santos,
I was heavily impressed and a lot of
people are juniors.
Done.
And then you see junior box the fucking
ears off of Ben Rothwell and you go to
junior's.
Not done at all better than ever.
That's just how good at over him.
It's how good overeem is.
I mean,
you're talking about a world class
kickboxer real world class Grom Prix
champion.
He's the most decorated guy in the UFC.
Striking wise.
Can you think of someone better hunt,
hunt,
uh,
you know,
is the only one.
But honestly when the hunt won the Grand
Prix,
hunt lost a decision and then the guy he
fought couldn't go on in the finals and
then he went on the finals in one.
Correct.
See the grand prixs is sketchy fucking
thing because you know,
it's a tournament.
And so you got to fight multiple times
in a night.
And if you fight a guy who won by first
round knockout and you went through a
three round war or even worse,
some of these guys went through through
like when Joe Schilling fought in that
last man standing tournament in Los
Angeles when he fought a Simon Marcus,
he went three rounds.
It was a draw.
They went to a fourth round and then he
knocked him out in a fourth round.
But he had been dropped in that fight.
And then you gotta think that fighting
like that is,
it's,
it's touch and go.
So the guy who makes it to the finals
might not be the best guy.
He might just be less beat up.
Very fuck.
It's kind of cool because it had a
little bit of luck to do with it a
little,
you know what I'm saying?
This punch lands I get out of there.
Well,
didn't overeem beat go con Saki in the
finals?
And I believe Saki had a broken arm
going into that fight.
That's right.
Yeah.
So there's that.
But over him,
as far as just pure striking right now,
I don't think there's anyone better
knocked out Badr Hari.
Yeah,
he did.
But the thing you had already stopped
him.
But he,
Kod Barnett bought her heart with a
fucking left hook from buhloone fucking
way bigger than what's been a high
thinking will bother her.
He,
he,
uh,
he's been known to dabble in the Mexican
supplements himself.
He got pretty God damn big,
but bought her heart.
Going through a bunch of personal
issues,
had been breaking dude's legs and
nightclubs to therapists are like
planets on fire.
He's crazy.
I mean,
you see means fuck all that whole camp.
Mike's Jim's filled with monsters.
Just Melvin Melvin manhoef.
Oh,
they got some monsters over their
monsters.
But the thing that my point was,
is for brock with his experience,
fight,
snack and monsters.
And right now brock doesn't need money,
although I'm sure he's getting paid the
most that I have any fighter ever right
now.
He doesn't need money.
He just do it for the competition.
Yeah.
Which it shows you the type of balls on
this dude.
Well,
he has the type of balls anyway,
I mean you're talking about a guy who
won the world title against Randy Coture
in his fourth professional fight.
Fucking crazy.
No,
that is crazy.
That's fucking crazy.
I mean it's David Goliath and David
verse,
but it's still randy fucking coture
randy couture.
Even though he might've been the David
in the David versus Goliath.
That's a tough out.
That's a tough fucking bullshit.
And you know,
and Randy has so much experience.
He's so grizzled.
That's where sometimes when like,
Huh,
well brock just saw and randy is.
Randy was just trying to strike with
them.
He's like standing in the pocket,
like slugging it out.
I think he thought that that would be
his best way to win.
You know,
I'm going to keep that big fucker off of
him and dropped him with a punch behind
the ear.
Yeah.
Prock is a gorilla.
He really is.
Just as a fig vanilla gorilla is a freak
man.
They got some balls on him.
Yeah,
no doubt about it.
But it's interesting that a guy takes
this much time off the sport and comes
back from,
comes off of two tremendous beatings
against two of the very best in the
division.
And they weren't close.
No,
it's not like,
you know,
John Jones got sooner,
Jon Jones dc where I went to decision.
We're like,
fuck,
I'd like to see that again.
Now you got murked and maybe he was
sick.
Granted he was saying he's sick.
Certainly for the gang fight,
for the cane fight,
he was sick.
And then for the overeem fight,
he's recovering from surgery by like six
months.
I mean cold blooded,
right?
The Gut,
right in the gut.
And you need them in the gut to your
van.
Yeah.
Over him just playing for keeps man.
Well you gotta do fucking God ever
looked.
Nobody has any sympathy for brock
[inaudible].
So it brought it to Frank Mir beat his
face in and then it was pointing at him
and screaming at him and frank was so
out of it.
He didn't even know what was going on.
I mean,
frank had just got sent to the outer
stretches of the universe.
That buildup was so rough though.
Remember Brock,
like walk off during the countdowns,
like how did it feel to get submitted?
Like,
fuck this.
Rip The mic up.
Yeah.
All right.
Well we can wait and then frank just
kept Jab,
Jab,
and then finally,
yeah,
he fucking,
he beat the shit out of them.
Tenderize that face.
It was awful.
So bad.
Tough to watch.
It was that Kayo and Shane's Kale of
mirror both of those two together.
If you watch those two side by silent.
Whoa.
It's referred to his guys had some tough
losses.
Tall.
He's been doing it since he was 19 and I
suspended,
right?
Yeah.
What did he test?
Positive for
the same shit that,
that stuff maybe melodion doubted.
It sounds like some shit from Krypton.
It doesn't sound fake.
Melodious he,
I don't think he,
he might have been taking some real
shit.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I mean heavy weight.
What are you doing taking that shit?
Well,
probably just trying to keep his muscle
mass.
You know,
there's a lot of guys that,
um,
especially like late into their career,
they start developing real testosterone
problems,
pituitary gland damage.
It's a real common issue with older
fighters as well with concussion,
with football and professional fighters.
Because with head trauma it lowers your
testosterone.
Yup.
Losie testosterone.
Even if you look the same,
you don't feel the same.
You feel depressed,
you have low energy,
you know,
even if you keep most of the muscle mass
or at least you look like it,
it's hard to tell.
You know,
a guy might weigh the same,
but now he might be 20 percent body fat
instead of 10 or 15,
so five percent more body fat.
But really the quality of his body,
the way it moves away,
it's just not the same.
Completely different.
And the last thing to go is power and
the speed and quickness the first.
But with heavyweight,
that's why you look at the heavyweight
division.
Everyone's old man,
they still have all this power left.
So it's hard.
It's hard with the heavy duty,
it's hard to tell a guy like frank,
you should probably retirement.
He was on our show awhile ago and he was
just coming off that loss and I was
going to ask about retirement.
He was even thinking Nice Candle.
No,
what would I do that look at the
division,
man.
Everyone's a whole.
It's hard to argue.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
It's really hard to argue because you
look at guys like or Lawsky who oldest
fuck came back almost a loss of time and
stopped so many times and just doing the
damn thing.
Just keep on keeping on what?
Chin crazy.
Just keep going.
It's crazy.
When you think about the deepest cut
world.
Champ came back.
Yeah.
All these older dudes.
Just boys.
Not Young.
No.
Roy was on fucking ultimate fighter.
Thirty six years old.
Just fucking Goddamn.
I'm 22.
What the fuck is he doing?
Their kids say?
It was like God dog.
What are you doing here?
Yeah.
What?
Uh,
there's not a lot of like fresh young
guns.
Steep as the youngest.
And he's.
And he's the champ.
How old?
Steep Bay.
30 base.
Thirty one.
He's in his prime.
Tough fighting.
It's over.
Raymond Cleveland.
Yeah.
Thirty three.
God,
Doug.
Yeah.
It's a tough fight against overeem.
Overeem right now has come into his own,
has gotten real comfortable and he's
into that Wim Hof breathing method.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
He's doing all that shit that.
That's made a big difference,
man.
I think psychologically it's made a big
difference too.
He's been working with Wim Hoff for
several fights now and he's won
something working for him with steep a.
everyone talks about these super cans
and you have to come from a super camp.
Not Steve Bay.
No,
I'm a fuck.
Is print out flyers and then jumping
into the gym.
Training with fucking billy from
Kinko's.
Whipping his ass became world champ.
You know what I'm saying?
When they fight in Cleveland.
What a card is that?
September?
That September,
right?
I think so.
God Damn.
When is that?
Jamie?
For steep ass.
He has to apply pressure,
but he,
you know,
he likes to wrestle and people forget
fucking over and can wrestle.
Man.
He certainly sounds probable.
I'm gonna fuck your kin Ras.
All any capital?
Yeah,
you certainly can.
What is it?
September 10th,
UFC 203.
Excellent.
That two.
Oh,
two card.
Yeah,
there's a lot of great cards coming up,
but let's pull up the graphic Jamie for
or two for for 200.
She almost said 100.
You think it's the greatest card of all
time,
Huh?
Man,
I'd have to agree with you.
It might be.
I mean look what we got here.
We've got Jon Jones and Daniel Cormier
is the main event.
That is an epic.
God damn fine.
That's an epic fight.
Epic.
I got a question for you joe.
Okay.
Let's say you could only watch one
fight.
It's either DC,
John Jones or listener Mark Hunt,
which gets more views.
More views.
Is Lesnar Hunt easy?
Yeah,
a hundred percent because I was without
lesbian on this card.
This thing ain't breaking records,
but me personally I want to watch DC and
Jones.
Me Personally,
but it's a very close second for the
freak show factor.
Lesnar hunts have very close second,
but DC and Jones is my number one pick
for that card because I want to see how
DC figures out.
Look,
I think DC,
when he fought Jones the first time,
I think John Jones fucked him up with
the wrestling.
I think he didn't expect that.
It didn't expect John to be so big and
strong.
I think John outperformed out,
outworked him,
beat them.
I think John just beat them.
I think DC's a better fighter now.
I think gotten,
having gotten through rumble,
having gone through Gustafson and uh,
I think dc
made some real good points about,
you know,
how he would have performed versus how
osp would have performed in that fight.
And it might've been an interesting
fight and I think he's coming into this
fight much more confident and much more
able to handle the trash.
Talking in the bullshit.
That first fight was super emotional,
super emotional.
It's getting a little emotional now.
You see Jon Jones get under the skin and
it doesn't phase John and I love DC DC
knows this.
I'm way closer,
decent.
I am done.
I just don't see what DC's going to do
different and his age and his training
camp,
what he's going to do different to beat
John.
Look at leg reach.
Jon's 45 inches DC zero.
They use.
How about you measure dcs legs?
Let's at least get it up there.
Everybody knows that John
has an advantage.
You can't just write zero inches fox,
so just take out both.
Who's running the fucking website?
How hard is it to do that?
If I was Dana White,
I'd be fucking details.
I'd be pulling my eyebrows out right
now.
You go crazy.
The fuck are you doing?
Why does it say zero?
That's not good.
I just don't.
I'm not that intrigued with this fight.
The same way.
So weird.
I don't know.
I'll get shit for it.
Like the dominant Cruz.
You at favorite did nothing for me.
Both those guys.
I wasn't then.
Yeah.
It wasn't like I got to see this DC
John.
I'm not.
Yeah,
it's weird.
I don't know why John.
Maybe you can help me with like with DC
John.
I'm more interested to see the version
of John that comes out because that Osp
one was very safe.
John just getting through to get to DC.
I that first fight to me wasn't that
close,
and then DC has one style fighting one
fucking stone and we've seen how that
goes against John.
Good luck,
man.
It was close enough that I think it's
intriguing because it was five rounds
and uh,
I,
I think dc lost the majority of the
rounds,
clearly lost a decision clearly,
but I think he,
he pose enough problems giving the fact
that I think that he was compromised
emotionally going into that fight.
I think he was overwhelmed and I think
he's learned and gotten better since
then.
So I'm curious.
I'm curious,
you know,
if I was a betting man who I am a
betting man,
you would 100 percent put money on John
Jones when you money based on the first
fight.
Yes.
You'd have to.
Then also,
I think John needed that warmup fight.
I think having a fight against a guy
like osp being off for 16 months and
then taking out a top six guy and Osp
was a dangerous motherfucker and beating
him and you know,
people say you didn't look good.
I just disagree.
I disagree.
I think it was a tough guy.
He fought a tough guy onboard.
Think,
yeah,
I think he performed very well.
So,
uh,
that's my number one fight for sure.
But for the freak show factor,
Lesner lesner hunts the freakiest freak
show of the freak shows.
And by the way,
when they were talking years ago,
when they were talking years ago about
Brock Lesnar coming back and Dana and I
want to have a conversation.
I said,
please mark on police.
Oh,
you asked.
That's what I was saying.
I was saying,
please.
I go,
that's the fight.
look,
if you got a guy who's the big fucking
power wrestler,
right.
That has a little bit of a problem with
striking a little,
little bit.
Yeah.
Who Do you.
Who Do you pick them up against?
Well,
you hit it,
pit them up against a guy who's built
like a fire hydrant.
Right?
He's only like five,
nine.
He's 265 pounds.
Got To cut weight to get down to 65.
He hits like a fucking asteroidal
impact.
Straight up.
Pretty takes a shot as good as anybody
that's ever lived.
He's got these legs that don't even look
real like his knees are like you took 13
knees and glued them together.
They look like to tortoise shell.
Fucking sea turtles.
So thick says everything about his
bones,
his head.
He's just deck and not.
He's not intimidated in the span of
Brock Lesnar by anything.
Nothing doesn't give a fuck.
Been there,
done that.
He's a warrior.
Brock Lesnar also zero inch leg reach.
Measure his legs.
You're giving them $50.
Billion Dollars.
Measure his fucking leg so it needs to
get on that.
He did to me.
So let's say worst case scenario for wwe
and the fucking UFC.
Let's say brock Lesnar,
he goes in there and it's like,
hi.
Hi.
Gets fucking
fucking triple h I'm knocking your
fucking had it to the third row.
So he gets merged in 30 seconds.
What is brock to psych?
Ah,
fuck.
You know what?
He's done.
It's over,
right?
Yeah.
Would have three in a row.
You got murked all three unless he just
decides like this is what I want to do
now.
And I only have like three or four years
left in my body.
What did we say was 38?
Is that we said Barack is.
I mean,
can't possibly have that much time left
in his body.
If he wants to wrestle,
he can draw that picture is 38.
Yeah.
So he's 38 years old.
I mean realistically a natural 38 year
old athlete.
It's just not much time.
There's not much time.
Like yeah,
like I'm looking at my watch and about
seven,
seven hours.
Yeah.
I mean unless you're a guy like Bernard
Hopkins and again,
and we using the word natural with air
quotes because boxing you can get away
with a lot of shit and not get caught
some shit.
So who the fuck knows?
I'm just saying hey,
I don't think he.
But.
So Sophie Beats Mark Hunt.
Let's say you get some down.
Fucking does is Brock Lesnar beat beats,
Mark Hunt and overeem beat Steve Bay.
They set it up.
God Brock Lesnar
not.
Could you imagine if the ratings would
go boom.
And that's not something outside of the
realm of possibility?
Not at all.
Neither one of those things.
Neither one of those things are outside
the realm of possibility.
If steep a beats.
Even if Steve Bay Beach Overeem,
I think you could still possibly make
that fight.
I think you make steep a brock.
Yes,
that's what I'm saying.
Steve.
A beats over him.
Yeah,
for sure.
But if over and beat Steve Bates and
natural 100 percent overeem gets on and
look at the difference in his body,
I looked the same.
He was on steroids.
Yeah.
Yes.
Then you set that up and if brock shoots
a fucking power,
double on overeem pins him against the
cage and beats him into oblivion.
Oh yeah.
The biggest star of all time.
Yeah.
He's the fucking time and he becomes the
new heavyweight champion.
Then Cain,
he wants to fight cane again.
Can I get some dealt with kings?
Got To get through Travis Browne.
I'll tell you what.
He's a big favorite.
Cain is a tough motherfucker.
As tough as they get.
He.
But you gotta think about the amount of
wear and tear on his body.
Correct.
We're talking about knee operations,
shoulder operations,
back operations.
There is a ton of stuff that's been
giving out on canes body,
so you have to,
you have to be concerned with whether or
not he can make it through full camps
that anesthesia can't be good for you.
Got It.
That's not
to.
He comes out with a big bubble ass what
happened when I'm under,
might as well get it done so I don't
have to go back.
Cane decided to get a job,
stuff like that.
So to me,
this is my,
uh,
if you're a betting man and you're like
draftkings or whatever.
This is my upset pick.
I think Travis Browne is,
you're upset.
Pick here because keynes had so many
injuries,
grantee went through a full camp with
DC.
It's a fucking tough fight,
man.
Travis Travis hasn't looked great,
right?
He poked in the eye,
he beat me.
He got knocked the fuck out by Orlowski,
but the fighting live poplars of monster
man.
He has A.
Well,
I'm concerned with his camp and the
amount of sparring partners he's
getting,
like he's not at Jackson's anymore,
which is just a hotbed.
And you know,
there's two schools of thought,
right?
There's one school of thought,
well,
he's getting much more individual
attention.
He's got one guy concentrating on them
all the time,
but he's working as Mitzi already knows
how to fight.
This is just an opportunity for and he's
working with curriculum Dell who's going
to help him tremendously with his
wrestling.
Rick,
he's a fantastic grappling in vegas
though,
right?
Is Vicky?
I think ricky was working with him.
He does.
He's been working with it for awhile,
but I don't know if he's full time.
Maybe it's going back and forth.
Either way.
Rick is one of the best in the business.
He's fantastic.
Very,
very smart guy too,
so I don't know.
I would have to find out and I will find
out this week what kind of training he's
getting in his camp.
Who is working with that makes a big
difference with the garlic travis,
especially when you're fighting a guy
like,
hey,
I wonder why travis moved away from
Jackson's.
Felt like that was such a great camp.
What do you think what it was his face?
What do you mean?
You wonder why?
I don't know.
Yeah,
I don't.
Do you
not really.
I mean,
he's off.
You're giving me the face.
It's like,
it's.
I feel like it's pretty obvious.
Right?
Don't like you moved.
He moved to Glendale,
his girlfriend's here.
They're living together like,
excuse me,
sir.
Okay.
That way.
You know what I'm saying?
That's,
that's not good enough for me.
Me fucking say Rhonda.
You ever thought about moving to New
Mexico?
It's fucking beautiful.
We'll go around the mountains together.
I'll find you a starbucks
gift card for starbucks is every time we
get a photo with her,
she's got a scene.
It just looks delicious.
Beverage.
There's nothing wrong with that,
but they hope made hopefully their
sponsor.
But uh,
yeah.
To me it's upset.
Pick if there is one on this card that
you're upset.
Pick.
Just because obviously I flat trousers.
He,
he's a fucking nightmare.
Deal with you.
So long.
He's explosive.
And Keynes come off this long layoff,
man.
He's always hurt.
There's gonna be some point and I
fucking guarantee it.
We're canes.
Not the same.
We're just like,
oh,
there it is.
It's like the age overnight because
camp,
he's been wrestling since he was fucking
two months old in diapers.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
it's also all the stuff that you're
looking at that breaks,
okay,
look at what's going on,
shoulders,
knees,
back,
all that stuff.
For those are.
Those are things that are real hard to
come back from something you're not
talking about.
Like a broken hand,
you know,
you're not talking about like snaps his
forearm.
You're talking about like critical
points of pressure,
right?
Credit,
critical stress points,
shoulders,
knees,
back when those things start going,
man,
as a fighter,
it's those.
But,
and how much time is he had to truly
rehab it.
Like we've seen pictures of his body
where it was just a few months ago and
you know,
quite honestly didn't look good
physically.
He's never looked good,
but he looked worse than he usually
does.
He's been steady on the burritos and not
just that,
but it's also like muscularly.
He didn't look like he was built up the
same way.
No.
Yeah,
I did not look good.
He's not the Quito Kid,
but uh,
if there's a time for Travis to ever get
Cain Velasquez and now's the time now
and remember,
this is a three round fight.
If it's five,
oh,
he taken you swimming sun into the deep
waters and it's fucking miserable as dos
Santos.
I'm a fucking.
Never been saying,
well,
three rounds with game.
If your Cardio's nice,
then you can deal with it.
You're going to get through it,
but five,
he's going to fucking break you.
But is it the same kane?
And if it is the same Kane,
if cane comes back and he's 100 percent
healthy and he's making that mad run
towards that title,
belting it's easy fight for them.
It becomes very interesting.
Yeah.
Then you're talking about a different
animal.
The cain,
Cain,
cain in his prime cane.
Like second fight with junior dos
Santos,
the Ben Rothwell fight like some of the
other fights that he had.
And he's a monster.
I mean,
I still maintain.
It's really between him and fader.
It's between him and a prime time pride
fader.
And a lot of people go with prime time
pride.
Fate or now you know,
for doom in there,
you certainly do.
You look at his when you certainly do.
He also beat King.
Yup.
He beat,
he beat,
he beat fade or he beat Cain.
He submitted,
um,
Minataro.
I mean submitted it frank.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
But that,
you know,
it's,
it's funny how if he never fought steep
bay,
you would say like,
Verdugo has emerged as one of the
greatest heavyweights of all time,
but he makes us mad.
Crazy.
Run at steep a like charges Adam.
That's that emotional,
crazy steep.
It was like,
hold up what debate is,
but what a beautiful sun the firehouse
son
enjoy Brazil
and the way he hit a moving away,
he was like,
what do you do it?
But boom,
like if you're coming into my shot.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
Um,
how about uh,
Misha Tate Amended Nunez?
That's an interesting one.
That's a very interesting fight.
My think about Nunez,
my concern is her cardio,
she comes out like a Bat Outta hell.
She'd certainly does.
And she's danger Russ as fuck.
But misha tate is as game as they come.
You know what the problem is though,
mischa's a slow starter,
like she always gets in trouble and
comes back.
But with Nunez she hits so fucking hard.
If you're a slow starter that first
round you're going to have to weatherman
by that first round.
Tate wins and honestly for.
And I know people hate on it,
but for the,
for the business tastes so good for the
sport man,
because she.
She looks fucking obviously she's
beautiful.
She speaks great and she's just a good
winter.
You know what I'm saying?
She's articulate.
She's just a good winner no doubt.
But for Brazil,
which is a huge market,
Amanda Nunez will be Gi.
They only have one champ right now.
Dos Anjos?
Yeah.
They said fuck that testing.
God dammit.
Really?
We're going to do that now.
Yeah.
And you got to wear reebok.
Goddammit.
Amanda Nunez.
Very interesting.
She means hope.
She really concentrate on cardio for
this camp.
That's all she should be doing.
Yeah.
This is a five round fight to.
Is she ever fought a five round fight
before and.
No Sir.
Yeah.
So that's interesting because cat on the
Prelim said ib both you bitches.
Well,
you know,
if you look at me,
she has fights like she has shown
remarkable ability to endure punches and
kicks.
Do you ever see her fight with Julia
Kedsey in strikeforce?
Julie Kenzie can fucking kick.
Oh yeah.
She's got some beautiful kicks,
beautiful technique.
And she caught me with a fucking cloying
or right on the chin and a meesha fought
it off and gutted it out and eventually
got a submission,
which is,
you're not,
you're not fighting off the Nunez.
Straight Punch to the face though.
She hits so fucking hard.
She gets so hard.
I think that would be troubled,
man.
But do you think she,
she punches his heart as Julie Kicks.
I say no fucking way.
Do you ever see that?
Five,
five years ago.
So that's true.
That's after Ronda beat her.
Then that was her next fight.
Somebody put up a,
um,
a highlight clip the other day of a
Julie Kenzie's kicks versus Misha Tate
cv could pull that up just where you go
wash your skin,
blasted in the face.
But there's this one,
she,
she got blasted a couple of times with
good,
good kicks,
like she hit it with a good front leg
side kick,
like I'm not totally sideways but like
Thai style to the,
to the chest center flying.
But there was this one high kick that
she caught her just perfect.
He says just,
it's interesting because you see her,
she's so soft spoken.
She's pretty,
you know,
you just wouldn't.
It does.
There's no indications of how mentally
tough she is.
She is tough as they come off as a
beast.
Yeah.
You know,
it's crazy to me,
as I was looking at this,
I'm like,
God,
who's beat them?
I looked up a b,
both of them and stopped.
Both of them are cats of monster cats.
Ferocious who camp.
Yeah,
she's ferocious alliance going to San
Diego.
She was at our show in Denver was awhile
ago,
the firing kid live show and she was in
the back and she's like,
I'm thinking about moving and you're
talking to her in the same camp.
I tore some cat.
If you're already thinking that it's
time to go because you're,
you're in this routine here,
you know her husband committed suicide,
you have all this negative energy here,
leave monster,
you'll be fine wherever you're at,
but you go got alliance,
they have monster down.
That can really help you out.
You start a new chapter.
It'll be like Eric del Fierro is the
unsung hero in mma.
Him and Mark Henry,
him and Mark Henry to the unsung heroes
in mma who were like elite,
top of the food chain,
world class coaches that don't
necessarily get the spotlight that they
deserve,
and also dominick Cruz who's been
helping cat quite a bit.
Did you find a video dude?
How about just the kicks?
I found the fight a few times,
but not had the last round.
There was no,
it was on twitter.
Somebody posted it up on twitter the
other day.
Dude,
how bad I was in this.
A goat cart thing with Jason Ellis and
Dominick Cruz is there.
You're,
you're competitive.
You're wasting fucking go carts.
I see Dominic Cruz in the corner hyping
himself up debts here.
It's gone.
They don't want you to win.
They don't want you to win this.
He's talking to himself,
oh my God.
And I'm like,
Oh,
this is love.
It was crazy.
He's playing for keeps and this guy
makes them.
He goes,
the guy who works there,
it's like some Costco fucking warehouse
thing.
They set up.
He goes,
fucking crazy.
And I went,
I guess man,
that's why he's world champ.
I tell Dick Jokes and work at Costco
because we think this is a game.
He doesn't brother.
One second.
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
They don't want you to win.
I was like curious.
Okay.
But yeah,
but restart.
Restart that could watch this.
Look at this.
Here's the sidekick.
Well that was no power.
Yeah,
but wait a minute.
There's the sidekick to the chest.
See how she's got it.
Like sort of Thai style.
It's almost like a butt sweat.
This leg kick.
Very nice.
But now here it comes.
Here's the clanger.
I mean,
come on.
How many people survived that?
That is a calling or a clanger to the
mug and Julie Carter with a punch.
And to think that not only did she
survive this,
but she went on to win by submission.
That's a woman's bat to the face
basically.
What?
That is just amazing.
Now Meesha,
she's as good as they come in for her to
keep one.
It's so good for,
for the women's division.
Yeah.
It's so fucking good.
Well really the rematch with her and
Rhonda is the fucking fight.
That's the fight.
And even more so than holly and Ronda
because they,
there's so much animosity might
disagree.
Well because me,
she just choked Talia unconscious.
I know.
But I think that that,
that Holly Rhonda rematch is way bigger
because we've never seen Ronnie just get
fucking Mert and dismantling that is
true.
And now she and she was talking about
suicide and she's been out of the
spotlight.
She came back and now she's facing that
same flow.
It's like,
oh fuck.
And she beats her.
Oh my God.
Or She just never comes back.
Well you don't know.
I mean she just got through knee
surgery.
So that's always an issue,
you know,
how long,
what's the extent,
the extent of the damage,
like what did she get taken care of?
I believe she had meniscus issues,
which is not the worst thing in the
world.
The best of all of them.
Yeah.
Well especially if you can get stem cell
shots in there,
which I'm sure she probably did.
Um,
so there's that.
So,
you know,
maybe she comes back and maybe she's got
more mobility and more,
more agility than ever because of taking
care of an issue that's been bothering
her.
You know,
this as much as anybody bothering her
for years maybe.
Maybe.
Oh,
it's just doesn't give a fuck about
fighting him.
Yeah,
there's that too.
I mean,
when you lose in such a devastating
fashion like that and then take a long
time off of it mean she without a doubt
has a warrior and a winner's mindset.
But for how long,
you know,
I mean,
does she,
she still want to do it that she.
Did she want to jump right back in the
way?
Holly wanted to jump right back in?
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm always weird comment,
the only thing that was a little strange
was
as the face of women's MMA and you lose
one fight and saying how you had
suicidal thoughts and talking about
don't be a do nothing bitch,
and the first thing you want to do,
you know what I'm saying?
And then as soon as,
as soon as it doesn't go your way,
like fuck this man,
I'm out.
It's like,
well that's not a champion.
You can't do that.
Well he was doing movies her.
It wasn't like she just said,
fuck you.
I'm out.
I'm not,
you know,
I'm done with this.
She had two movie set up,
one of them being a remake of roadhouse.
It's a big movie.
So craziness to hold the whole thing is
a big craziness.
Right.
So she's got,
she's got these two movies,
she's got the knee surgery,
she's got love.
Yeah man.
It's a lot going on.
Lot going on,
but as long as,
as long as she's happy,
she doesn't own anyone,
anyone,
anything.
Like she could just rather than sunset
and make all these movies and be like,
fuck it man.
What I did for the,
she's good now what she did for the
sport,
she sat for women's fighting,
but do you think that she would ever be
happy going out with a loss like that?
That's the,
the issue that see that.
That's for her to answer.
That's tough man.
And then there's also,
you know,
she has the Holly Holm lost,
she needs to redeem and then now you got
sideboard in that bitch and that's the
super fight.
Everyone.
Let's see.
Cyborg is like,
let's go chomping at the fucking bit.
So while you're making movies,
sideboard,
sit in this fucking speed bag.
Like at their job,
which it is night and day,
just waiting for us to get upset.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's tough man.
But I think what's crazy to me is,
you know,
when cyberworks coming out me,
she's one of the only girls who was
like,
I'll fight her fucking nuts.
Yeah.
What else?
Wanted to find a mistake saying that now
she's the other title.
Well,
but not at that 35 should do it.
Yeah.
At 35.
You're the champ.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
From invicta.
Why do I give a fuck?
What's me?
You?
No,
you Misha tate.
Meet me.
You're the one who needs this.
I don't.
I wonder if she can make 1:35.
I mean she made 1:42.
Did Not look good when she was at the
way in.
I mean she looks like skeletor 35 going
to be tough.
But if you want those big money fights.
But look,
here's the bottom line with Christian
bale made 1:10 when he was in that
stupid fucking movie.
He's the on stupid talking about Dallas
buyers club.
No,
not that one.
That was um.
Oh,
matthew mcconaughey.
That's right.
But he also made like 97 pounds.
Yeah,
straight dad.
Christian Bale's was in a stupid movie
that nobody watched called the machine.
He almost died.
You've seen that,
right?
I've seen pictures of him getting there.
Yeah.
Mikaila.
He fucked his body up doing that.
I'm sure he did.
He said he's never been to say,
oh fuck sakes.
Yeah.
Matthew mcconaughey.
He said he'd never been the same again.
Yeah,
he goes,
I.
He goes,
I was doing it naturally.
He was doing,
this is the center for Das bicycling.
He goes,
yeah man,
I was losing all this weight and you get
to a certain point where my diet,
I just couldn't lose anymore.
It didn't look like edades ridiculous.
He goes,
then I know he didn't say why he took me
was then I had to do some aftermarket
shit to get even lower and bigger.
You read.
He was always like your big,
strong.
He's like,
I've never been the same.
My body never came back the same ever.
Yeah,
especially like Matthew mcconaughey.
He's in his forties,
so you start doing that to your body
when you're in your forties and just
wreck it and you know your testosterone
levels are low diversity system.
It devastates your endocrine system.
Have you ever seen like there he is.
Jesus Christ.
He looked bad.
That diamond piece before now look.
Yeah,
it looks like tales from the crypt.
Mad Mike or Magic.
Mike mentioned my to
look at them though.
Talk about being both deepen,
hacked in God.
Look out batty locked motherfucker.
Take his aids.
He must have felt like you had a good
movie too.
It was a good movie.
Yeah.
He fucking sold me magic.
Mike,
you're talking about.
Fuck.
No,
just kidding.
That's not bad either.
But uh,
the thing is like girls who do those,
you know,
those figure competitions cut all that
way.
Yes.
My Buddy's girlfriend did that and my
brother's wife did that.
They never,
they never go back to the same man.
They just don't like their thyroid.
Everything's all fucked up on them
because they lose all this weight.
Yeah.
And then the body was in.
Their hormones are all fucked up.
It's a nightmare,
man.
To get down that low.
Your body's like,
what do you do?
Especially for a woman,
right?
Because body fats are usually higher for
women than there are for men,
but it's got to be the same for men too.
Guys.
Bodybuilders and they get down to that
shredded three percent.
Body fat.
We see everything.
Strike patients.
So when you're doing it just for other
day,
meanwhile you're covered with tanning
solution.
That orange,
black basically with buck because
someone's like,
God,
that black garlic shredded and I'm white
as fuck.
I thought I get black.
How weird is that?
It's true.
Muscles.
Look,
they look.
They pop more when you're dark.
Yeah.
Well you could see him better.
It's so weird.
It's like a white car.
It doesn't show the line.
Get this.
Just a meat heads at Gold's gym.
I used to work out there all the time,
but I saw a video of John Claude van
Damme saying,
no,
kicking is bullshit and doc and he can
help guys.
You see that?
Come on Bro.
Come on.
And I love John.
I love John.
Well,
you know how crazy John Claude van Damme
was right about making blockbuster
movies.
That's hasn't been crazy about that for
a long time.
How have you seen.
Have you seen any of his reality show?
But yeah,
he was a drunk.
He had a great reality show on showtime.
Was it?
It was on showtime,
Jvc,
D Jakes,
cbd.
I know that's a movie.
No,
no.
They put it on showtime for like a week.
Really dumb is flat as shown in his
house.
His wife.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm going to have to fight again for the
children because I called behind closed
doors.
That's what it's called,
but there's a.
there's one scene with several times
where he indicates he's gonna fight.
This guy from Thailand who was wanting
to Olympic gold medalist in boxing and
he sets this fight up and he's like,
I'm running around doing all the cocaine
and all of this and I'll have to show
the children that I can get back and I
have to fight road.
So he has like all these press
conferences set up for him and this guy
are squaring off.
What the fuck?
I never saw that.
I saw JC.
Here's a show behind closed doors.
By the way,
this,
this is from like seven or eight years
ago.
No,
I,
I saw this.
I didn't see that episode that you're
talking about though.
I've seen this bullshit.
He's up.
He's still pulling some numbers though.
Like he's flying private.
Has this sick ass crib and I don't know
story.
They just don't fucking,
just like it hardy into hot cocoa.
He knows he's riding that Bolivia
marching powder right off sunset.
That age is the fuck Outta here dude.
He looks every bit of 60.
I don't know what he is,
but as soon as the eighties,
I think fuck.
And he had.
He had some surgery to fucking picture.
Where's this?
You can see the Dick route
right up to the top of those lines are
fucked out.
They're like,
what are we doing?
Why is he holding up?
Look at the picture above that though,
where it looks like the joker that,
oh my God damn.
Is that real?
And that's makeup he has makeup on.
Oh my God.
Holy Fuck.
Wow.
But that's cocaine,
man.
Cocaine.
Just does that.
Cocaine and bad life decisions.
Yeah.
I mean,
how old is Sean Claude Van Damme?
Let's take a guess.
I say 55.
Does that make sense?
I'll say God damn,
if he's 50 he likes.
So he's the most shot out.
Fifty five year old.
I'm gonna.
Look,
I'm going to say 58.
Fifty 5:00 AM,
right?
Fuck.
Look at that.
That's insane.
Because Tom Cruise is probably like 52
and Tom Cruise looks sensation or
whether you're talking about
scientology,
she didn't know what it is.
They're helping them.
Hydrated judges.
Just rub it in there.
Look,
he's 54 for the same age,
they're the same age,
one year difference.
And look how fucking stunning this dime
piece is killing the game.
There's a big difference there,
man.
That is a big difference.
He's also never been hit in the face
before.
That's true.
But neither is wrong.
Claude van Damme.
So dear you sir.
He has a kickboxing record.
No,
he does not.
Point karate.
Fighting backgrounds and kickboxing.
Jamie,
I don't buy it.
How do you know?
I don't think so.
I think he might've fought some point
karate tournaments.
I really don't think he.
He kicked boxed.
You think you just mark them if you guys
owe me and him?
Yeah.
Well what are we do when we do an MMA?
Are we doing straight up fight?
Oh,
kickboxing.
Yeah.
I don't think he has any power.
Eighteen and one that's not necessarily
true.
Well,
let's see.
There's a fought on tape.
See this as a karate fight,
right?
Or is this a kickboxing fight?
What is this?
Nineteen,
79.
Fight on tape.
Let's say caught on tape.
Okay.
What is this?
This is point fighting.
Fuck fuckers fluid though.
Yeah,
I mean he was just got tagged gold.
Gold.
You always holding the trophy.
Yeah,
I mean look,
he most likely had some form of
competition experience,
but was he 18 and one in kickboxing for
real?
I don't know.
Eighteen one means you got to fight for
it.
Look,
most people don't have more than four
fights in a year.
So you're fighting for a long period of
time.
Did that say pro?
No,
just said 18 and one kick because back
then it could be an amateur because you
know smokers are just blowing through
it.
Yeah,
look,
it's possible.
I'm not saying I believe that I want to
believe it because he's one of my hair.
No doubt the guy had some pretty kicks,
but the problem with the way he kicks,
he's like got like point kicks.
Like flippy.
Yeah.
They're like flipkey,
flipkey kicks,
kickboxing and full contact karate
career began to fullcontact current 77.
Wow.
Seventy seven.
Hold on a second.
That would mean he would be like,
how old was he?
Like 18.
Okay.
I'm a little bullshit.
Eighteen knockouts and one defeat.
He was even named Mr Belgium in a
bodybuilding competition in the game.
I mean,
maybe here's the guy winning just since
2009 v Van Dams in planning to make a
comeback,
fight to fight former box Olympic gold
medalists.
Some luck.
Cam Singh,
who is a tie.
I'm boxing champion.
The fight was a focal point of the ITV
reality show.
John Claude van Damme,
behind closed doors.
The fight has been repeatedly postpone
which many critics doubting it will
occur.
I don't know why they would doubt at
this point,
especially to reach out to the gym.
The difficulty of booking the venue.
Oh yeah,
because that's hard.
In Thailand.
There's six year olds fighting every
fucking Tuesday.
I mean,
look at this.
In December 2012,
Van Damme was seen as a part of Cam
sings ring crew.
When cam seeing fought against Jon hawed
a con and say that guy's name,
chuck cluck,
cluck,
cluck left us.
Say that name K I a t a d I s a k,
l a this Zach.
Anyway,
colorful name maybe.
I mean maybe he had some legit
kickboxing fights.
That sounds like some world association
of kickboxing organizations that one of
the problems with kickboxing,
there's some callen shit.
Yeah,
same shit.
Oh No,
master Kim.
One of the problems with kickboxing is
there's a lot of world championship
organizations a lot.
Whereas like say if you and me started
up our own organization said,
hey,
you know Brendan,
I've been thinking,
man,
you and I should do a fucking
collaboration.
We're going to do a kickboxer
organizations.
We're going to have the fighter and the
kid slash J R,
e world championship kickboxing matches,
and then we would just crown some dude
world champion and we don't really have.
It's not like the WBC for boxing.
No,
it's not lifted the UFC for mma.
It's just like my.
Those tons.
I don't know how many world
championships there are,
especially in United States.
There was a ton of them.
I know that for a fact and you go
worldwide,
but it's not.
It's not like Bella tour calls their
guy,
the world champion like Bella tour world
title,
you know,
like the word of.
Well they can't go.
They can't say the second best world
champ.
You know,
it's like God damn world champion a
world champion is a world champion.
You know,
you could say Bella Tor champion,
but when you say world title,
the Beltour world title,
it's not the world,
but stop please.
But that's fighting.
That's why.
That's why like in the Mba,
the calves or the world champ,
there's no one on this fucking earth
being those five guys.
That's true.
Higher world.
That's NFL,
NBA world champions boxing,
mma.
It's like there's all this
chick is the world heavyweight champion.
One hundred percent.
Who the fuck is it?
Who else has the claim?
Best heavyweight MMA fighters in the
world or in the UFC?
No doubt about it.
Steve Bay's the best of the best.
He knocked out for doom.
He's the world heavyweight champ.
Correct?
It's the only belt that really count.
Yeah,
that's the UFC belt really counts.
The only way the UFC belt is even in
contention is in some of the lighter
weight classes you start going like home
would happen if this guy fought that guy
who I disagreed,
but not even.
They're not even.
Not even that really.
That's the only place I agree,
like Marlon Moraes is a very talented
guy,
right?
He's a 1:45 or right at 1:35.
One 45 or write my own Mirage,
but the,
the fights for a world series of
fighting.
He's a legit like world class fighter.
I see.
But this is why the UFC,
it really only is the belt that counts
because if he fought in the UFC you
ain't going straight to the bell.
You going through the fucking ringer.
Who's who at 45 to get to that belt.
Which everyone did.
Which Alvarez did to memorize a.
was he 1:35?
Yeah.
So he's a bantamweight,
legitimate threat to,
in my opinion,
anybody in the UFC at 1:35.
I mean,
could he really hit Dominic Cruz?
Who the fuck knows?
But look at that guy.
That guy is a savage.
That's a legit world class fighter.
Skeptical hybels on that buddy.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He is bad motherfucker.
That guy's super talented.
But unless you're in the UFC,
no one gives a.
nobody gives a fuck.
It's weird because you know,
he's,
he's one of the few guys outside the UFC
that like,
like just engages in other one.
If you guys outside the UFC where I go,
I want to see that fucking guy fight the
best of the best.
I mean,
I see like real mad potential and that
kid,
he's another one.
He's the world series of fighting 50
slash 55 champion.
Yeah,
it's an animal.
Kid's a fucking animal.
He's a beast.
Man.
He started with us in Denver was a
restroom.
You,
UNC.
He's just a monster.
But again,
you look at the guys he's beating for
these title 100 percent.
You're right.
One hundred percent.
No,
no debate whatsoever.
And there ain't any growing either in
the UFC know because you come from a
world champ.
Look,
look at will Brooke's first fight bras.
Pearson?
Yup.
Yeah.
He's going right into the hot.
I mean that's,
that's the,
that's the nature of the beast with UFC,
right?
It's no different than the NBA or nfl.
Like you're not.
There's no easy.
You're not getting cakewalks and you
have this contract.
They're paying a shitload of money.
I mean,
so there can be no doubt that the UFC
1:35 pounds a month,
55 champions are the champions of the
world,
but there is talent in some other way
classes.
There's talent in some other
organizations.
We'll
get Eddie Alvarez.
Everyone was like,
God,
I want how you doing the UFC world title
now.
He'd be the first guy with a belt or
title in UFC title and I think Chandler,
a guy beat him once and lost him second
time.
I think Chandler looks even better now.
Better than ever.
I mean to be knocked out,
but tricky.
Pippa like,
good Lord,
he's explosive.
He's so quick with his entries and exit.
His footwork was fantastic and he's a
guy who was doing some pretty extensive
fucking camps to get ready for this
spectacular workout ethic or work ethic.
Where do you think.
Because a guy like a guy like chandler
who's just killing the game,
right?
Like he has a shitload of.
But this is the thing though.
Joe.
Let's say you're his.
His manager.
He's the.
He's the king of Bela tour.
Let's say he's pulling in small and six
figures
for sure.
Sponsorship money included so high six
figures or per fight,
they come to the UFC strips.
It's going to be a different animal.
Now,
it's true as a fighter,
no one's ever going to say you're the,
your pound for pound best.
That's just never going to happen.
This just not the only way to do this is
what I think.
He's a champ.
Chandlers and 1:55 pound champ.
This is.
He's got two options.
Either he sticks it out with Bella and
Bella tour continues to grow.
Um,
but even my man,
Jimmy Smith,
who is,
in my opinion,
one of the best fucking commentators in
the world,
they make him have to fake excitement
about like Ken shamrock versus Hoists
Gracie.
They're doing ultimate hunting.
They're not doing good moves.
These are not good moves.
That one was bad.
That's a bad move.
But you know,
for a guy like Jimmy Smith who was like
a legit fan,
as well as being an excellent
commentator,
like that's a bad place to be,
to have to,
you know,
you're making this guy have to hype up
some Horse Shit.
You want that paycheck bitch get crunk
Ken shamrock hoists,
Gracie,
seven dot 5,000 and Kimbo.
It'd be crunk like Justin combat.
You better be crunk too.
Like it's Mike Tyson holyfield.
We've taking half your paycheck.
Know there's no,
there's nothing good about that.
So I hope they don't have to do that
anymore.
Hopefully step away from that.
But you know,
like the chandler fire,
chandler could.
It's conceivable that if spike really
keeps pumping and keep putting it up and
keeps,
you know,
firing up the coals of promotion that
they get to a point where people start
mentioning Chandler alongside other
guys,
you to sign more guys like,
I don't know what the deal is with
reading Mcdonald.
His contract is up.
Granted he lost a wonderboy.
But I,
you know,
I know bell tours can make a strong push
to sign that dude.
But you got to get these free agents and
have a stable because right now,
you know what I'm saying?
We just like,
look at,
look at UFC $200.
What the fuck amy person on it?
Any tandem could fight for a main event
and belt or any night of the week.
Oh yeah.
Sage.
Northcutt could.
Sage northcutt would be fucking brock
lesnar over there.
The minibar.
That is ridiculous.
Sure.
It'd be a mini brock lesnar.
Did you see his comments?
What is.
I said the,
his last fight.
It was a fluke.
Potential death.
Not flukes son.
That's not a fluke.
Yeah.
Well you're just young.
Yeah,
he's a young kid.
I'm a fan.
He certainly did have a strep throat
going into that fight that's been
documented.
And you know,
someone choking you while you get strep
throat.
You're going to tap pretty fucking
quick.
You have some serious inflammation in
your neck.
And.
But Brian,
Barbara arena is a fucking animal.
He's an animal.
All right.
You saw how he,
um,
he beat a.
what's his name?
Homeboy.
The Brazilian cat that was undefeated.
A.
God dammit.
God Damn it.
I can't remember his name.
Warley.
Alvez.
I beat that dude who is a beast.
Undefeated guy won the ultimate fighter
for Brazil.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Worldly.
Elvis.
He's a beast and Barbara Barbarina beat
him in a war,
so can't call it a fluke.
[inaudible] CIOCCA.
Like getting nicked by right hand and
getting drop.
You can say it's a fluke.
Stylize it closed.
I saw even a fluke.
Wanted to punch you.
He punched.
You can chalk that up more as a fluke.
Then a fucking submission that was
calculated like,
no,
no.
I decided to take it down and choke you
out.
There's no food like I went through the
steps.
Choked you out.
God Damn.
He's fighting.
Enrique Mirin Wasabi.
That's his nickname was obregon was
sadly spicy.
Like Sushi,
like the green stuff on Sushi and stuff.
I don't know anything about Enrique.
Do nothing besides the names.
You have a UFC.
The
click on him.
Jamie.
See if you've got a UFC record on him.
Bom,
bom.
Scroll up please.
Is that as the UFC record?
Yeah.
So he does have a split decision loss.
But that's not,
yeah,
UFC fight night.
November 21st.
He uh,
okay.
Probably good fight for sage.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what I mean.
Antibiotics,
that's the kind of fight that he really
shouldn't be taking 100 percent guys who
were thrown to the wolves and build a
kid up.
I mean the kid's 21 years old because
even 21,
he's 29 slash 20.
Right.
But for Stud,
here's the fucking sleeper that no one's
talking about.
Tj dillashaw how fell.
Sun Sail.
That's a tough fight for Tj.
I remember.
Yeah.
And who won a sunset in Brazil,
but very,
very close.
Some people had tj winning [inaudible]
yeah.
Tj,
I'm needs this fight,
this fight.
There's a couple of guys on this car and
I'll go who really need the to win.
But I think
sometimes a little tank man,
he's a super tank.
You know,
Tj is the biggest favorite on this card.
Really.
I think four to one.
I think just because a sense I was past
record,
you know,
like what's the catch?
How much of your favorite is cane over
brown?
Uh,
I think,
uh,
Brown like plus 2:25,
right?
Huh?
We'll look at that as Jamie was Jamie
and with the quickness to 80,
to 90 to 90.
See,
that's my upset pick of the night if I'm
good at.
Yeah,
I could see.
I could see that being John Jones is a
big favorite.
Look at that.
That makes sense.
You know,
but there's a couple of people who need
wins.
I mean Jose Aldo and Joseph Aldo.
Man,
he's been gone for awhile.
He got murked by Mcgregor.
Tough Shit.
Kind of need to.
When Travis Brown,
he loses this one.
It's tough,
man.
Hmm.
I'm surprised that that uh,
Aldo and edgar is basically dead even.
Really?
Who would you give it to?
Although,
boy,
it's
hard.
I guess I'm not surprised because you
really don't fucking know.
If you go back and look at all those
past performances,
you look at his last fight with Chad
Mendez before he fight mcgregor,
before he fought mcgregor.
Fight.
Ever.
Fantastic fight.
Um,
I don't know,
man.
That's a tough one to call.
It used to be even in the odds.
It's weird.
That's a fucking tough fight to call
them in and the fact that conor was able
to start something like that and frankie
just shows no sign of slowing down.
No,
that's where he is a fucking animal.
He posted videos of his workout,
a workout before you went to Vegas.
He's doing fucking handstands and
backflips and he's a monster man.
A
title shot.
So bad.
He certainly does.
I'm very curious about this fight,
although he's never been knocked out
like that before.
Nope.
So we've never seen how he responds.
Exactly.
He could just be a demon of Brazilian
demon.
Fucking Merck's Frankie.
It's such a good fight.
Well,
frank had a really hard time with his
leg kicks in that first fight and
really,
really hug.
And um,
this was also,
you know,
pre Usada true.
And also frankie,
he's,
he's been on a straight wind streets on
Merkin dudes.
Cub,
Swanson fight.
Just relentless Mendez.
Bj Penn.
Yeah.
Frankie has been on a tear,
You know,
who needs to win.
Like I'm fuck him.
Johnny hendricks.
He does.
and there's not an easy fight at all.
It's a weird message.
Especially iF calvin comes in and shape,
especially if calvin doesn't have a hard
time making weight.
Calvin's a beast,
man.
He's a light on his feet.
He throws off real quick hands.
He's got great footwork and he's a
southpaw.
There's a very similar.
They're very similar,
but it's way more agile though on his
feet.
See way more footwork.
see,
I think johnny puts things together
better and I think I think kevin's going
to struggle with because calvin is
usually.
He's that grinder like ho ho wrestle.
You know what I'm saying?
He still those big bombs.
Well shit.
That's johnny's fucking gay man.
I think.
Great fight.
It is a great fight,
but I think calvin just needs to be
really,
really focused for this fight he has to.
This is a giant important step for him.
For both of them.
What happens is the giant lose this one
that's three in a row,
son.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you're right.
And this is a big one.
This is a really big one because he's,
you know,
he's facing a young kid on the way up,
was not top 10 right now.
The risky fight for johnny.
It's weird.
There's certain fights in your career
where it's like a fork in the road,
man.
Yeah.
Where you go and it's so competitive.
Especially at this weight class now it's
like you lose the kelvin fuck man.
WeLl,
johnny's lack of mobility got exposed
and the wonderboy fight will fuck who's
done It.
Yeah.
Wonder boys just on another level when
it comes to that karate style.
But I also think johnny,
he was,
you know,
he's always been on discipline outside
camps.
It's catching up with them now.
There's no,
you know,
there's no ivs,
so it's,
it's ah ha ha.
You have to be disciplined.
We want to fight at the world class
level.
You got to be disciplined outside camp
now.
He just didn't look like a killer in
that fight.
He just didn't look like the same.
Johnny didn't look.
I've been joHnny hendricks at,
knocked out marvin camp men or martin
kampmann or the Johnny Hendricks.
He knocked out fitch or the robbie
lawler fight.
Yeah,
I think he had fire in his eyes and
those fights and you got to also take
into consideration a lot of distractions
outside the octagon.
He stArted a fucking restaurant member,
started a restaurant,
Texas.
he owned break open a steakhouse and it
went under with the quickness.
Not mad at that idea though.
Do the reviews were hard to shitty
service.
This terrible food.
Cooking steaks and shit.
I don't know what he was a bad idea,
but why would you do that in the middle
of your competitive career?
I mean,
I don't know who fucking told him to do
that.
Well,
he probably just invested in it.
Whatever.
It doesn't affect his training.
It affects.
you will remember he left that camp
though.
Yes.
He left with the.
In their agreement was we take a
percentage of this and we pay for
everything and things was like fuck this
man.
I'm out.
And then he hasn't been the same man.
Well they paid for everything too.
They gave hIm a salary and then they
had,
they had hired all these trainers.
Will all these camps.
He's super camps.
They all hemorrhage cash,
you know,
like the black zillions are in a
situation right now because the owner
just declared bankruptcy.
Did you hear about that,
Glenn Robinson?
Yeah.
make sure that's true.
It is.
It's.
Yeah,
it's that it wasn't affecting the black
zillions at the time.
Excuse me,
sir.
No money.
Listen funds that.
The only way those things make money,
the only way those camps make money.
Oh,
the only way is if they become
successful for a long period of time.
Like jackson's were like jackson's done
it the right way.
They have world champions.
They have elite high level athletes
train there all the time.
They slowly develop a massive fuCking
clientele.
They have massive amounts of students so
people are paying dues and they can
expand its students though.
That's the key word.
You students pay the bill though.
Hilton and the flutters bring the
attention,
but most people don't do that.
Yeah,
like blackzilians.
I don't think that for any classes they
paid like overindulge a gillion dollars
to ladies and that didn't even work.
Worked out by himself in the corner.
Yeah.
I apparently didn't enjoy training with
everybody else.
Yeah,
I mean that's not play well with others.
He,
you know,
he threw a lot of cash at people.
It's,
it's terrible.
Just a rich guy that doesn't know the
sport tool manufacturer with more than
10 million in debt filed chapter 11.
see that ain't good.
She said tool,
when you have more than 10 million in
debt,
that means jamie,
you're richer than him because he owes
10 million bucks.
You don't know $10 million.
So went.
So this guy's running around like he's
rich driving fucking ferrari's and shit.
Like,
no,
you're not rich anymore.
You,
you fucked
up.
You spend all your money on overeem.
And we met the.
Yeah,
that's right.
The adults met reality show.
The ultimate fighter man.
That was with the black zealand's and
american top team.
Yeah.
This was like the focal point when the
guy arguing a our season ever.
I don't want to see two rich guys argue
about as fighters.
Well dan lambert is a,
an actual guy who trains.
I mean I think he's got his black belt
now.
I'm super legit.
I mean,
he was a brown belt for a long time and
he's a real fan of the sport and if it
was anybody that deserves credit for not
just keeping that team alive,
american top team,
but dumping a ton of money into
investing a ton of money into the sport
and developing a legit world class
facility.
It's dan lambert that guide needs.
He deserves all the props in the world.
He's legit as fuck off my tv though.
But a
ak is done the fucking thing.
Yes.
They've done it the right way.
They never went back.
They never went into debt.
They did it smart if students.
Yup.
Students,
you've got to have students.
Got to have students.
Well,
you know what it is,
man.
These guys like if you look at that guy
from the black sea lanes,
no offense,
but let's just be real.
That guy's a doughboy.
He's got a big fat face.
Probably never good at any sports.
And uh,
you wanted to be in with the cool guys
to be associated with them.
Yeah.
So he deCided he's going to pay for
everything.
Maybe he's a big fan of sport.
Invests a lot of money in it and good
for him.
Look,
he maintained it for this long,
which is way longer than most people
would have.
if you really stop and think about it.
You just can't be a smart business
banking into the sport and dump all that
cash.
You'd have to be some rupert murdoch
type character that's got just fucking
kajillions.
You can't have 10 million debt with your
tool company.
Can't.
Sorry dude.
And then pay over him all this money or
I'll come and then it gets into.
I'm not working out the same time.
Everyone else says.
He's like,
fuck,
I didn't even think about this.
Oh yeah bitch.
We're fighters.
We have the biggest egos ever.
So it might.
It doesn't work like that.
You just don't plug and play guys,
man,
you don't.
You Have to be able to figure out some
way to make a team and then it's also
not a team sport.
So what happens when,
you know,
like att is dealing with right now with
robby lauer about the fight,
tyron woodley?
No.
You have to figure out a way to navigate
those waters.
This is the first time atts had to deal
with it.
It's a good problem to Have though.
It's a very good problem to have,
but the thing is you got to invest in
young guys too.
You know what I'm saying?
Like he can't just be about the
superstars.
Yeah.
Of young guys coming up and they're the
guys that you built up.
Then you have to have class.
It's just a fucking terrible business
plan.
let's.
Yeah,
you have your real moron,
but you got to be a guy like dan lambert
who is very wealthy but truly
legitimately loves the sport.
Dan loves the sport,
but if you pulled dan aside and talked
to him about the headaches,
he'll just go off fucking christ dance.
Super honest about it.
Yeah.
I wonder if you could go back in time if
you do it.
Of course he would.
He just built a new facility.
Built flourish.
Huge gigantic plate.
How's he so rich?
He's a baller.
He's got.
He's just very successful in.
He's got a bunch
of shitty tool company and no tool
company.
He's a legitimate,
you know,
super wealthy dude who's a legitimate
fan of mma.
I've been friends with dan for shit
going on like 15 years.
I've known him.
He's always been like that.
I've talked to him once.
He was super nice to me.
We went to see the ifl.
He and I,
uh,
and eddie bravo went to see the ifl
together school.
Yeah.
Where was that?
I want to say it's in like fucking New
Jersey or something like that.
Att for a while was the biggest camp
ever remember?
They had like thiago alves that big
foot.
Who else?
They have that?
Hector lumbar.
They just had the who's who?
It was like the number one spot to be
at.
I remember for the longest time.
Yeah.
Kimbo went down there.
I'll be lawler king mo said Mark Hunt.
Yup.
Well blackzilians extracted people from
att.
They paid paid people to go over there
and there was like a big exodus where a
bunch of people just get their bills
paid and you know,
dude threw some money at him.
He wanted to build up a team.
I did half my camp for a nogueira down
there.
Yeah,
I wasn't with rashad.
Um,
I mean it was good sparring because it
was like rashad rumble.
Johnson just rumble.
Yeah.
Was that,
I mean nightmare.
We just think we only did one round,
but he wasn't in camp so he's kind of
like,
whatever.
He's a fucking nightmare.
He's huge.
He's like,
you're bigger than me.
I'm fighting that.
Everyone's weird.
Super nice guy and he can wrestle his
ass off this people don't know,
just fucking rest.
Dot athlete of the camp was good there,
but it was.
Rashad was getting ready for a fight
too.
I forget who's getting ready for.
Oh john.
I may have been john,
but
you know,
it was about rashawn rashad's the
captain of that team.
It's just weird,
man.
You know,
if,
I don't know they've invested in you.
It was a good switch up for me because
my managers down there and he had a huge
house.
I needed a change and different sparring
partners.
So I flew down there for two weeks and
then fly back and forth as you can tell,
probably wasn't the smartest.
The fight didn't go.
Carets seemed like a good facility down
there.
It was.
All right.
Just.
Just all right.
Yeah,
nothing,
nothing crazy.
Just all right.
Compared to other gyms.
Yeah.
What is the best facility right now?
Going?
Is it att tristar?
Tristar.
How so?
I think tristar,
because for ross,
he,
you know,
he's not
like,
he doesn't want fame.
He's,
he was a fighter himself.
He's ridiculous.
At kickboxing,
jujitsu.
He teaches the jujitsu in a geeky.
So there's their students,
so he's not riding,
dying off the paycheck of rory or gsp,
stuff like that.
There's professional boxers that work
out there.
They have a boxing ring,
they have an octagon,
don't.
It's just a,
it's like a,
it's a motivating environment as far as
like other gyms.
It's intimidating.
You know what I'm saying?
Does that make sense?
Yes,
it does.
Like I remember going to jackson jackson
world class,
best of the best,
but it was like nonstop sparring and I
was like,
fuck man.
My,
my coaches from denver weren't there
when I'd go there,
so it was like I just always,
I'm so intimidated there all the time
because it was just straight up banging.
Yeah,
that could be a problem too,
right at the balance between sparring
and technical work.
Like a keith jardine and I were just
together.
Haven't seen keith for ever chiesa close
friend man and I look at keith because
keith and he's doing the act and now
he's doing well and he was talking about
the podcast game,
all this stuff and we're laughing.
I go pro.
Remember how we used to fucking spar?
Remember you go in,
you would do a round with me.
You'd stay in.
Shame would climb in.
You do two rounds with him and then I
would jump in.
He goes,
what the fuck were we thinking?
Dude,
you guys are older than me.
I thought you guys knew what was up.
He goes,
insane,
man in st stephen goes,
I wish I would've stopped sooner.
Here's those last couple.
I wish someone had told me because we
were talking about our lives.
I wish someone would've told me.
He goes,
I wish I would have stopped sooner.
Now here's the last one.
We're wasting my time because we were
talking about mutual friend.
We have a very close friend.
I'm like,
fuck,
I wish she would stop man.
He's like,
you just talked to another dates.
I dunno man.
They still want to do it.
Yeah.
It's hard to get a guy to walk away from
it because everything else is so muted
in dl and the experience of competing is
such a massive,
massive rush of excitement and the
bleakness of the possibilities and the
opportunities outside of the cage.
Yeah.
And if,
if,
but if that,
the issue is,
if that's your identity,
like most any athlete,
not just fighters,
football players,
boxers,
basketball players,
if that's your identity,
like you're known as mr.
Fighter and mr.
Basketball.
It's a depressing man.
Super depressing.
All right,
let's look at that card.
What else we got on that card?
Um,
so what do you,
what do you like in the frankie and
aldo?
That's the toughest fight for me to pick
it.
Really.
If you take away the last fight with
frankie or with a aldo and conor,
then it becomes a tough fight for
frankie to when frank has got to be at
his best.
Right?
He's an underdog,
but frankie,
you look at his victories and you gotta
think he looks better than ever like
frankie's,
that he's in his prime right now.
Will unquestionably in his prime the cub
swanson fight chose that the.
I mean,
your wife's favorite fight was not very
impressive that uriah faber fight was a
fight where he just sort of one,
but it was not that big of a deal.
Right?
It's fucking tough to finish,
man.
He is tough to finish.
But dominick cruz beat the shit out of
him and dominick cruz did it in a much
more convincing way.
You know frankie beat Him.
The Chad mendez fight with spectacular
first round knockout.
That was amazing.
And you can't.
Mma.
Math never works.
We all know this,
but when you see what frankie did to
Chad mendez,
they look at more that aldo in Chad
mendez had.
It's just so impressive,
right?
But then you look at what aldo did to
uriah faber,
beat the fucking brakes off him.
He beat the fucking life out of them,
beat the life out of them.
Then you look at frankie did room.
It's not as impressive and maybe math
doesn't work,
doesn't work.
and then you got to remember now that
there's new testing involved.
I'm not saying on things,
but I'm saying we only have one
brazilian champ before.
Had many more.
Even though you know,
forget about just talking about
resilience.
I go all fighters across the board.
When you see first of all,
although is now,
what is he 32 holds.
Although if you had to guess 31,
31.
Uh,
I would say so he's in the neighborhood,
right?
What do we got here?
Twenty nine.
Okay.
It's in the neighborhood and fight for.
I've been fighting for a long time.
Had some incredible,
incredible fights.
But you,
you've definitely seen a change in his
physique.
and then you could say,
well you go back to like the first Chad
mendez fight in particular,
just tracked.
BuT you got to think,
okay,
well he also had a hard time making 1:45
back then.
So it could be that he decided to lean
out because it's easier on it's cardio,
you know,
there's a lot going on there.
But didn't chat.
Chat tested positive too recently,
right?
Yes he did.
Yeah.
He tested positive for some peptides.
I think growth hormone,
peptides to move.
Saucy isn't on the fucking undercard
against leonardo santos and santos.
Excuse me.
And no one's even fucking Talking.
Jim miller gummies kicks the flight path
off.
These us gummies.
Like I'm the first fight of the night.
What the fuck?
It's good for him.
He go.
Me is the way he performs lately has
been a shell of himself.
I mean it's just winging giant bombs and
hands down and plotting and you know,
jim miller is a guy who's just had wars,
so many wars.
So it's joe lozan man.
Like I'll watch joe lowe's on flights
and then like.
And I love the dude.
He's one of my favorites.
Mr. Bonus
stuff,
man.
It is tough.
It's like where you know,
what happens there.
And I'll tell you what,
cat zingano and juliana opinion is very
interesting for the bantamweight
division,
for the women's bantamweight division
because catching up.
First of all right there,
she jacked.
She's even leaner now is shame.
Yeah.
You'll see new pictures of her.
Good for her.
Well is a tough fight for her man.
Real tough fight.
Julianna pena is a beast.
And their friends to write a.
They're not friends.
Uh,
Kenya and tate taylor.
A friend.
Really close.
Yeah.
Which is interesting because they might
have to fight pen.
Yes.
It sign me up.
Yeah.
I mean she's got to say that girls don't
care man.
She's just difference for the title.
Dudes are like,
I don't know.
Girls like I will fuck her up.
God damn girl relapses a.
This is an interesting fight.
Striking wise cat has a big advantage of
grappling.
I'd cat you
think so cat as well in grappling.
Julianna pena can grapple,
man.
She's strong as fuck.
Dude.
Cat is so fucking strong.
She,
she threw calendar around like a fucking
rag doll.
I was,
I got on video.
Do you just say cowen?
Yeah.
A grown man though.
Or is he really?
Is he really by whose?
Whose definition?
Other than 35 pound man.
Did he try to grapple with her?
No.
Oh yeah.
Poor baby.
Awesome.
Uh,
he of all the p,
he's got body dysmorphia the opposite
way.
Most people think they're smaller than
they are.
Like I was like,
why would you grapple cat?
Well,
not only that,
he doesn't train at all ever.
I mean he,
he like,
he like hit the mitts.
I guess nine.
He does something that's supposedly.
It's kind of like sparring.
Don't get me started.
It'S a good fight though.
This is a good fact.
What's interesting is they started
standing up,
can't counted her because cat Wrestled
in high school and then she won worlds
as a,
I think a white belt.
you like,
kat,
can you.
She gets cramped and she's,
you know,
she's a thick girl.
Girl,
strong man.
When she tried some loren landow and
she's a,
the number she puts up,
she's a beast.
She's no joke.
Strong girl.
Very tough in that fucking meesha take
kao,
which you carried her with.
That elbow wound killed both those girls
go fucking chairmanship,
she's nasty,
goodness,
suicide and all that stuff.
So she took a shitload of time off and
then she lost him literally 13 seconds
to rhonda,
but she,
she was sayIng how,
and it's true,
like her head coach leaster bolin who
she left to go to alliance,
she was saying he was like the issue
with her.
She never wants to game plan and watch
tape.
She Just wants to fight and scrap.
Right.
Which at a certain level you just can't.
You just can't.
You can't.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a sport.
You do have to game plan tendencies and
she never wanted to.
She hated it.
It made her,
it stressed her out.
So the,
the coaches would do it but tell her.
But like in that ronda fight,
hey man,
you can't brunch straight at her and
just get an bar in 13 seconds.
Yeah.
Like you just can't.
And so now she's at alliance and she's
like this,
the first vital I'm going to have a game
plan for.
So it could be good.
Could be.
It's interesting.
Yeah.
It could be for some,
it's not for everyone,
you know what I'm saying?
Like they think too much.
Julianna pena is going to be at a
disadvantage striking,
but I don't know if she's going to be at
a disadvantage.
Grappling opinions.
Fucking beast on the ground.
[inaudible].
Interesting.
Very interesting.
Very good.
I think cat has an advantage as far as
just sIze and strength that she's
fucking strong women for a girl.
This is a fucking crazy card.
LiKe look at this.
Now we just keep going.
It's almost like christmas at a rich
kid's house straight.
Just keep opening 10 minutes.
Rich rich
aunt's house and just fucking open
prevalence these fucking president.
Fuck man.
I mean by the end of the night I'm going
to be exhausted dude.
Yeah,
I'm going on vacation.
Usually I wouldn't give a fuck.
But um,
I will find somewhere to watch ufc 200.
Yeah.
Well you know,
if you have fight pass,
you could watch paper view from your
laptop.
Do you know that?
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
You can get paper view from fight pass.
I'm going to Hawaii though.
There's a fight town.
It is a fight town,
um,
but I watched a fight pass on my tv the
other day or watched a paper view
because uh,
I forgot to order a paper view once and
so I bought it off a fight pass and I
was like,
oh yeah,
you can just get it off.
Bypass this pretty dope.
That's fucking awesome man.
I don't fuck with fight pass.
Well,
apple tv is the shit.
I love apple tv and a ufc fight pass as
an app.
You can download it from anyone.
Watch ufc fight pass right on apple tv.
It's pretty dope.
Oh my god.
You have every fight ever.
And I use my phone as my remote control.
They're selling me on this show.
It's like an ad and
I don't know.
Yeah,
I'll find someone out there to watch you
gotta watch.
Yeah.
I can't go to the bar man.
It's too intense for so.
Highest stakes on the card.
Like dilla shot.
Just coming off one fight.
One fight ago.
He was a world Champion.
loses a super close decision.
Had dominick cruz super close.
You lose this one though.
See ya.
I know,
but like think about that loses a close
decision.
No one's talking about a rematch,
right?
No one's clamoring for a rematch.
I mean this guy goes out there.
Merck's hanan barao fights Joe Soto on
one day's notice.
Beat him down,
beat him in the face,
then goes in and my works and,
and borrow.
The second time he came out just
destroys him.
No,
no,
no.
Loses a close close decision to dominick
cruz.
And everybody's like,
yeah,
a hold.
not really interested in anymore the
sports.
Fuck you.
But for tj,
that's fucking crazy.
I mean the kid was not only did I like
and I said this and I meant it
wholeheartedly.
I said,
not only did He submit his position as a
champion when he beat hanan barao the
second time,
but I said he made a very good argument
for being one of the best pound for
pound fighters in the world.
I think after that hennen browne fight,
I was thinking he's like top 10,
maybe even like top five or six pound
fighters in the world is tough,
but he's taught 10.
It's tough.
It's tough now.
It's tough because you lost the decision
to cruise.
See if he beats cruz,
then you go.
Well,
the kids got a real argument there.
He's top five and he could have beaten
him.
Man.
Look,
all tj dillashaw needed was a few more
well placed leg kicks in tHat fight.
If he had gone in concentrated Heavily
on that right leg kick,
dominick cruz out a fucked up foot
memory.
That plantar fasciitis,
which is brutal.
And uh,
I mean he could have easily,
could have easily went that way.
He also started planting his feet,
digging his toes in.
Yeah,
he was headhunting.
He was trying to dominic fuck with his
head man.
Dominic got in there.
I want to see that fight.
I don't see tj and dominant.
Fuck yes,
that's what I want to see.
But yeah,
I don't know what they're going to do.
Who's dominant going to find next to.
Does he have a fight scheduled?
No,
but they need to fucking to tj.
Tj wants this thing.
You go tj,
uriah.
Then they need to do dj for cruz or john
motherfucking dotson at 1:35.
John dodson at 1:35 is terrifying.
He also beat tj on ultimate fighter k
odom.
He killed him and he is fast as fuck and
lights people on fire.
Think tj.
When's this one that gets a title shot?
He might not win this one.
Let me know.
I'm just saying if he does,
he lost this guy.
He could or he might have to fight
dodson.
If he loses fighting dot.
What if he wins?
He might fight dots.
I don't think you do that because if you
hate ratings,
you got to go.
Uriah faber or dominick cruz.
Next.
Tj,
tj.
Uriah faber is where the money's at.
That's the play and What's left for
here.
I met a man.
That wouldn't be so fun.
It was so cloSe though.
That makes me sad anymore.
Yeah,
that makes me sad.
it really does.
Yeah.
That's a bummer because when two guys
are bros like that bros before hoes,
what happened to that?
Nobody says that anymore.
No,
that's old school now.
TJ and uriah were so tight and soak in.
Tj still tight with Chad.
Chad and him was still buddies and joe
as well.
They're still buddies,
but you right?
Like you hold a grudge.
I think they both do.
That's why the fight would make sense.
We'd be crunk for it too.
Well,
I wonder like how much your rise got
left in the tank.
I didn't like the way dominic was
hurting him in that fight.
I was like,
rule dot makes a fucking months.
Here's a monster.
But he's never been known to be a
knockout artists other than the
[inaudible] fight.
He murdered.
Mr. Got smashed.
That dude's fucking.
But he had.
He had you're rioting and trouble in
real trouble and he put your riot in a
defensive shell multiple times.
But let me tell you something.
This is an unheralded guide.
How fIle sun out number three in the
world.
Okay.
And as far as contenders,
tj is the number one contender,
but half hour is.
No one's talkinG about him,
man.
He's fucking dangerous.
So this is a really tough fight for tj
because you got a guy who's already
beaten by decision is questionable as it
is and it's close.
It's close a decision that is as it is.
He's a fucking tough out for anybody,
man.
It's no joke and it's not doing tj any
favors.
No like sense out.
He's number three in the world.
No one knows who he is.
He's a fucking nightmare and he's beat
him before.
Like it's not doing tj any favors and
it's,
you know,
it's one of those fights where no one's
talking about It,
man.
I mean it's how came you look at this
fucking card?
It's,
it's,
it's gonna be a tough card to stand out.
Forget about the bonuses.
Who's getting a bonus in this fucking
car?
Those bonuses,
this,
there's something about those bonuses
that bugged me on ufc 200.
It's tough.
They throw a bonus,
but it's just something
about it that bugs me.
It's like that.
You're,
you're fighting to hope that day decided
that you get extra money and let me tell
you something.
What do you think?
You're getting it and then they
announced you're not.
I felt like crying when I beat michio.
Now's the whole lot.
I was the first heavyweight ever in the
ufc heavyweight to win by anaconda
choked the first doc.
They didn't and I was like,
I'm just darson mer anaconda.
Oh,
dark,
sorry doris.
I was like,
damn,
I'm getting that bonus.
So I was thinking about how to spend the
money and you put them to sleep,
sleep,
sleep in the first round.
And we were like,
oh,
you're for sure.
Again,
it some dude on the undercard one by
guillotine and they gave it to him.
Dude,
my feelings were,
I was at the press conference.
Super sad panda.
like I lost the fight.
I felt like crying.
Oh,
gets 50 g's back.
Like damn son,
50,000 sizzla bitch.
We go,
we don't benihanas for everybody here.
50,000 is always 50,000 who you are?
Yeah,
it's always 50 grand.
It's a lot when you're a struggling
father.
Fifty gs.
You're like,
damn I,
should I buy a rolls royce?
Should I get that mansion?
Like you don't realize,
you know,
I'm like,
should I buy a place in naples?
Ah,
we'll see.
Let's talk to the financial advisor.
this is the one fight where I'm,
I'm a big fan of tj as a person.
I liked that dude a lot.
Fucking love him.
I love him as well.
I'm looking at this fight and mark.
Woo.
This is a tough fight.
This is a very tough part.
I might be the the one of the more
difficult fight to call in the card,
but here's the thing.
When tj fought hoffeld sun sal the first
time,
he was a very different fighters.
pre bang ludwig who was a different guy
and it was in Brazil and it was barely
one.
Yeah.
Tough fight.
But a son sow.
Who is a [inaudible] last victory.
Jamie,
please trim up that lower region.
So.
No,
no,
no.
Keep it furry.
Cute.
Referring.
So you guys that brazilian forest on
this furry and stinky and stanky
Norway.
That's a fucking.
When he beat caraway munoz.
Jim when?
Yeah,
he's no joke man.
He had a lot oF time off though.
Cause the injuries.
Yeah.
Look at that man.
He fought dillashaw only two fights ago
to [inaudible] crate and then his last
fight with two,
2014 against caraway and that the care
was tough as nails.
He beat von [inaudible] by submission.
Vons.
Good submission guy too.
And then a split decision versus tj,
which was the close fight,
unanimous versus pedro munoz.
And then beat brian caraway and other
unanimous decision.
Look tobar fourth,
tWo thousand 14.
Yeah,
it was a long time.
Long ass fucking time,
man.
You shouldn't see what tj is the huge
favorite.
Well he definitely should be.
You should be a favorite,
but I can't imagine the sun sal hasn't
been.
I mean,
first of all got better for sure.
If he's been training
with the lights.
Sizzling hot,
you know fans.
Sheri leaman.
Yeah.
And he's not going to be in Brazil.
Yup.
What does that mean and what does it
mean?
You tell me.
What does it mean?
What is that face?
You guys down there?
If you have a lock on this card,
what's the log?
A jon jones.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
By far.
Interesting.
Because you look like you go through it.
John's btc before.
It's pretty easy for them.
You will get less than.
I do not think it's easy for them at
all.
Not easy.
I'm saying how great john is.
Yes,
that's my lock man.
All right.
And then lesnar hunt,
it's like,
I don't fucking know hunt if he gets his
ass down.
Well hunting fucking trouble trouble if,
if brock just bullies his way in and
blast doubles his asked to next friday
and then drops those lunchboxes on his
head and we're still hunt out.
So his.
So his fucking power's not there.
Yeah.
So that one,
I don't know.
They can go either way.
And then tate nunez.
Good luck picking that.
Although edgar space,
even money,
you don't think tate is a favorite
intake nunez?
Oh she is for sure.
But it's still,
it's a tough fight.
Tough fight.
The tough.
I can knock out anybody.
I really believe that that piston
righthand that she hid a sara mcmann
with woo.
And then mischa's a slow starter.
So it's,
you know,
if she eats was huge.
Fucking righthand nunez can grapple to
she.
She's a black belt but I still give me
sure.
The advantage on the ground that's
interesting in wrestling.
Right?
And scrambles grappling or just overall
mma grappling.
She's as tough as fucking nails did the
hollY.
That shit was so impressive man.
Like she's just waiting for.
It was so impressive.
So that fight stuff to call.
Although edgar,
good luck with that luck with that good
luck column that we don't know who the
fuck aldo is right now.
No idea.
We reallY need to find out.
You might be on the revenge tour and
just merge.
Frankie,
who grabs the mic and calls out connor,
who knows,
but I just don't see american frankie.
I don't think.
I don't see anybody at 1:45 murking
frank.
No,
me neither.
Man was trying to create drama here.
Yeah,
I don't see that man.
I see it at frankie at 1:45 is a
monster.
She just merck.
Chad and he's just better than ever.
Just keeps getting better and better and
better.
That's where you belong.
So yeAh,
45.
Look at his footwork.
Cardio,
everything.
He's not.
He was struggling to make 45.
He could make 35.
He's a 35 or you look at the size of him
in comparison to like tj and a lot of
those guys who were already five.
That's his weight class.
I agree.
He might eventually go down there too,
by the way.
He's talked about it,
you know,
fucking gray.
Maynard is fighting this week at one.
I Think he's fighting featherweight.
What?
Gray?
Maine.
It's fine at feather away.
Dare just let that soak in.
Where in the ufc
what gray maynard.
Pretty sure he must be fighting on the
undercard of the friday night fights.
Unless,
unless this brain trauma kicked in.
I'm making shit up now.
No parents.
Look at that gray
maynard is fighting.
Fernando bruno.
Whoa.
That's at featherweight.
Wow.
That's interesting man.
He got and he was a huge 50 fiver like
bulk lies.
Yeah.
Well he was carrying way too much meat
for sure.
And that was,
that was probably a big factor
in a lot of his uh,
his decision to get lean was the ivy
ban.
You being that big at 1:55 and having
all that bulk on them,
he probably decided to lean out and then
as he was leaning out it was probably
like,
you know what,
with his frame and its power and might
even be better at 1:45.
But he was just so much things that god
damn bully 50 fiber,
that's because he likes those dogs.
I was bullied dogs.
I get it.
But still,
he's the thick dude.
He was a thick,
but it was all muscle.
The only muscle.
Look on his,
his length please.
And then you lose that muscle and now
you've got 45.
And really it's,
you know,
his chin's been suspect.
So he cuts the 45 more than suspect.
I mean it's all your shit.
He's lost four in a row.
That shit went.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
The,
at least the last one was a decision.
Last one was in 2012,
so I know.
And he lost three by kao in a row.
Ross pearson,
odom,
which,
and it was ugly.
Nate diaz beat the fuck out of him.
That was a first round kl and tj grant
beat the fuck out of him.
Tj grant.
Here's a guy about to fight for the
title,
gets a concussion,
has to delay it.
And now he works in a mine.
He's done.
I saw him the other day.
He was there for someone's fight.
I forget who it was,
but he looks like he hasn't been
trained.
It looks thick,
like it's just been thicker than a
snickers.
Just fucking mind.
A very skillful guy to man and smart guy
too.
Very smart.
well,
that's why he's not fighting anymore.
You know,
he's not,
he's not a guy who takes concussions
lightly.
He stays there for hara as another guy
that looked fucking sensational at one
point in his career and his,
uh,
started to fade.
One of the biggest freaks ever seen
inside the gym for arrow.
Click on that fucking freak.
Yeah.
Who did he just lose to go click on his.
He's,
this is a middle way,
right?
Because you fight in middleweight.
Yeah.
He got knocked out his last fight.
Do you fight?
Oh yeah.
Bamboo say.
Oh no.
We saw them lose the Missouri model.
That's right.
Yeah.
We saw them lose some mazda.
Your code.
And then sam also,
while they bamboo say beaten by
decision,
but mazda dot kao them.
Click on watch that.
I don't even remember that.
Yeah.
Click on watch.
He gets in these slug fest to make us
sign up for five west.
We should be signed up already know.
Oh son,
what's up?
We can't show it on the podcast,
but we could watch it,
right.
Just it's a first round kao.
I just want to see how knocked him out.
He's so aThletic and he's good at
everything
he was.
He was to allege under amston silva for
years.
Then the little machida leo machida and
then be tour bell for like everyone
invest all this time and because he's
such a freak inside the gym,
housing outside of the students ever
going to lose.
And then he goes on the ultimate
fighter.
He's Just a monster,
but for a reason.
It's just not clicking for them in the
right now.
While he won the ultimate fighter and a
in the finals.
He fought our surgery more eyes.
The jujItsu black belt.
Who um,
he's the guy who tapped out.
I'm kron gracie and crohn's first black
belt match.
She,
sergio marTinez is a beast.
he is a world world class.
Black belt brazilian jujitsu.
But a mariah's caught ses are for heroin
with a hard elbow,
I believe in that fight and have.
I'm stunned because I remember I watched
it.
I was in Brazil for that one there.
There's,
there's a couple guys that I've trained
with and I'm just like,
dude,
these guys are gonna take over the
world.
Todd duffy.
I asked canaan dc because he went,
he left our camp.
One of them like,
how tough is duffy?
Like unbelievable man.
How'd that they get fucking robocop?
Maybe just need some like vinny shoreman
type mental coaching or something.
You know?
I mean there's,
there's been guys like that,
you know,
in football too.
You're like,
holy fuck,
this guy's gonna rush for 3000 yards.
Then the lights turn on and it's like,
what the fuck happened though?
Well,
duffy's fight against frank mir was just
real crazy.
Like,
what a nutty fucking slug fest.
Those too sick.
What?
Just let's go.
And to think that frank mir decided to
fight like that after all these years in
the game,
all his submission victories,
all his crazy fights against world class
fighters.
He just said,
you know what?
Let's fucking,
he's in love with box right now.
All I talked about blogs and I'm like,
for sure.
Jump.
God,
that's so weird,
man.
Pharaoh.
So for harris trYing to pass here and
somehow or another in this fight,
he gets knocked out.
I don't remember What the time was.
There's vitorin his corner.
He's bodied up and he did,
he did that cap or a and he can like,
he can do it to a t like a fucking
break,
just anywhere.
Flips all this shit.
And he's big too.
He saw athletic man,
the nicest guy.
If,
if he got his fucking head right man
playing the guy has the skills to do
crazy things and you think that's what
it is.
It's a head thing.
100 percent.
He's got tagged on the break there by,
by a
tough fight for them to this young in
his career.
Mazda was very crisp.
He's fucking vet.
Yeah.
Very crisp with his striking though.
I'm like,
I'm a big fan of the way he uh,
he throws punches like fast and
accurate,
but it doesn't load up on anything.
I feel like it gets there.
Yeah.
I feel like because he has a pro box and
experiences,
I feel like whenever go the decision
moskva dog gets fucked.
HE does get fucked every time he's won.
He's one of my favorite fighters to
watch.
She's good at everything was very smart.
Very smart dude.
He was a kimbo slice this fight back
yard.
Yeah.
In those early days,
man,
I've watched some of his fights before,
long before he ever came to the ufc.
Back when he was fighting even words in
bodog fight member that.
Oh yeah.
He caught eve edwards with a head kick.
Knocked them out and bodog
bodog.
Yeah.
Well that's cool man.
So detail son.
Another guy named jeremiah constant.
Yes.
Son and funded to postdoc at the hottest
ring.
Girls out.
Fuck was,
you know,
putin had a hand in that,
but if I could just get one night with
puente and paint the town red.
Do you remember?
Or white?
Do you remember that?
Calvin icing icing.
I do that calvin ira guy who owned
bodog.
Yes.
He was a guy who wasn't even allowed to
come back to America because he wasn't
involved in internet gambling because
the internet gambling used to be
completely legit,
but the casinos fucking bribed.
Everybody went,
fuck,
stop this.
Stop it.
Eaters.
They ruined what could have been an
amazing marketplace.
huge,
amazing.
But they wanted to preserve casinos in
the United States.
And especially when it comes to sports
betting and things along those lines.
So calvin,
I or he got fucked as did a.
what's that guy's name?
Kevin trudeau.
Remember that guy that fucking the 10
weight loss secrets that they don't want
you to know about.
Remember that guy,
those late night infomercial swindles
were swindled people and weight loss
tips like that turned out to all be
bullshit.
The guy was a swindler,
but he got fucked too because he started
something called the international pool
tour.
Oh,
right hand.
That's what it is.
Oh dude.
Mosbey doll.
He's a beast.
So he,
a trudeau started this thing called the
international prob,
uh,
international pool tour,
I thinK it was,
or ipt,
international professional,
whatever the fuck it was.
But it was a pro pool organization,
spent a ton of money on it.
It's terrible.
It is now,
but the idea behind we'll pool is
enormous and asia and enormous and a lot
of europe and other parts of the world
and his idea was have online gambling
and the online gambling would,
would people would bet on who was going
to win each match and they would make
their profits off that as he was putting
this together that came down.
The band on online gambling just crushed
it.
The Whole business got crushed.
He's in jail now for some portion but
hiding money somewhere and he's like,
he's one of those dudes that's in Jail
and they're like,
look,
let you out.
If you tell us where the money is,
fuck you.
Oh yeah,
you will let me out when you let me out.
And then I'm going to go right to that
fucking coffee can that I got buried in
my backyard.
Dude.
I felt slimy watching bodog like you
knew this,
like some weird shit going on.
It was so strange,
man.
I don't think they paid matt lindland.
I think matt lindland got fucked,
if I remember correctly,
or it didn't get paid all that there
were supposed to pay him because lynn,
lynn,
lynn lynn was supposed to get like a
million bucks to fader member that
lindland fought fader and fader cheated.
Remember that?
Linda?
Matt lindland had a body lock on.
I'm just taking him down.
Your fucking hooked the rope and totally
cheating.
Reverse the position and then went to
work and then went to work and armbar
them.
That's right.
Ain't no.
Once I went to the ground,
he did what he's supposed to do,
but you fucking cheated to get there.
He definitely cheated mother Russia and
this was when fader was fade or to did.
I used to use boat.
I used to use it to bet on sports.
Really?
Yeah.
Well that dude,
when he was had bodog fight,
he had a giant billboard just outside of
vegas for bodog fight,
you know?
It was on the billboard.
Him in a suit type mo.
These motherfuckers versions do it here
in la.
We shouldn't do that because first of
all,
he's already rich as fuck.
How much pussy do you need?
Dude,
you're going to have a surplus of pussy
and then you're gonna have problems
because paid for it.
Now plotting against you,
the pussy is going to be overflowing,
left and right.
You're not gonna.
Be able to keep a hand on it.
Shouldn't get in the way.
I'm gonna.
Get in the way.
You're thinking you're going to be.
I know this motherfucker.
You got fighters.
You got a bunch of fighters and you can
guess what?
They're fucking all those girls cry.
Bitch,
what are you doing?
You need to.
You need an advisor and it weird.
Famous guy.
Well,
it's like rich guys want to get famous.
Yes they do.
Yeah.
A lot of them do a lot of reason why
that Glenn Robinson went blackzilians
and get the stable effect.
You get enough money.
What the fuck you're doing?
I don't to do that.
Why did he go on television was a big
fat face on the ultimate fighter.
Fuck it.
We're dan lambert.
Just lambasted him.
Yeah,
he did destroy it.
Just destroyed.
Just chewed them apart and glenn
couldn't say anything.
Was he going to.
You can't,
like dan could legitimately beat the
fuck out of many times he wants like in
real life.
So it's like you can't,
there's not a lot of insults.
He could lay his when.
I mean just the whole,
hey,
who's idea was that?
I mean ultimately it's good for the
teams to show like who's the better,
you know,
what's the better team?
Who's got the better athletes?
Just get the better fighters and coach
jaylen's won that season,
right?
Yeah,
they did.
Yeah.
How'd that turn out?
Bitches bankrupt now.
He spent a lot of money doing what?
A bad idea.
It's not a good idea,
but bodog fight went under and I don't
know why it went under,
but they,
the guy was like mocking dana and he was
saying at one point in time,
you know,
that he would like to take dana with him
on his jet setting lifestyle and show
him,
you know,
I invited him to pick him up in his
private jet and so dana could see like
how he lives and what fuck it was back
before the ufc.
He really became the ufc in air quotes,
you know,
still.
Yeah,
still grow.
See,
but is that real?
I don't know if that's real.
There's so much confidentiality.
Nobody wants to give me a fucking
straight story.
I would assume it's real.
Where there's smoke,
there's fire and because it's weird.
They offered 4 billion and dana was
like,
effort.
You left for 4 billion.
I think if somebody offers you 4
billion,
you've got to say yes.
Hell yes.
Good luck.
Scratched together.
4 billion.
Like there was a number of partners,
but even then,
good luck scratching again at 4 billion.
It's a lot of money and you know,
you got to make sure that everything's
in place.
I mean,
it's a tricky thing.
You.
First of all,
you'd have to have dana stay on.
You have to have dana.
Without dana,
you don't have the same organization.
You're not going to be able to put
together the fights the same way.
You know,
you don't have the same guy doing the
press conferences,
the same figurehead.
It's very important.
Stolen.
Why would you buy it?
Anyone that with that ego,
if they have 4 billion or get these
three mega companies,
the other by 3 billion or 4 billion,
they're going to have other ideas for
the organization so you can't buy it and
then just leaving all the same.
You buy it and you give dana a piece,
so not only do you pay him,
but you also give him a piece of the new
organization so that he can get even
stupid richer.
You came a piece,
but you're going to have to have someone
like,
let's say you.
You hire a dude from fucking apple to
come in and run it.
This grant is not.
Let's say that's your idea though.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if you're buying,
you're not buying it like,
oh yeah,
you just keep doing what you do.
Your bikes.
You have some ideas like you don't
become a millionaire because you're
fucking using someone else's ideas.
Right?
Yeah,
that's true.
You must have some ideas,
but it's possible that it's an ego
purchase that a bunch of guys got
together.
Wouldn't be awesome.
If we own the ufc and they find out,
okay,
what's the revenue every year they make
x amount per year,
you know?
Uh,
so look,
if we put together x amount of billions
of dollars,
they have fight pass.
That brings in a fuck load of money.
Now fight pass has a lot of members and
they're paying.
I don't remember how much I,
I'm a member of fight pass.
I don't remember how much I pay,
but I think it's like nine bucks a month
or something like that.
Sure.
That makes sense.
For sure.
Give to joe rogan for free.
Just pay.
I pay for a lot of things.
Yeah.
I don't mind paying.
I hear you for sure.
My own supplements
I'll get sponsored.
but um,
this,
I think that if they were smart they
would,
they would see that there's a lot of
value in it.
But is there enough value to come up
with $4,000,000,000 to pay for it?
I think there's one way to look at this
where someone might say,
all right,
they've been running it like the goal of
boy's club let.
What happens if we didn't make this a
legit league?
Like you have a commissioner and you
have a fighters' union.
what if we ran a junior for warming
money?
I'm just saying that.
I mean you're.
If you're going to bite,
you have to have a different idea.
You know what I'm saying?
They can just run it as it is.
HeY,
can you can scale facility purchase?
Yeah.
You do the exact same thing and maybe
with buying it you can nullify the
reebok deal.
Someone might just fucking hate reebok.
Sorry,
I'm a bike just to get rid of it.
You just keep doing the same thing.
It's not a bad idea.
If I for pilling on reebok,
my buyer to do that,
What have we done?
Joint.
Just get someone else take this over.
So mad at us.
So much.
Hey,
we haven't seen a kitten years on the
streets.
Will do.
There was issues with the crossfit folks
to really.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I know one of the dudes at andy stumpf
was involved in that crossfit.
Ed edwards was telling me he doesn't
even know if ufc.
He's like,
who the fuck is wearing reply,
we a beat this thing to death.
I didn't bring it up,
but we're talking about kendrick lamar
and I was like,
yeah,
he's sponsored by.
I was trying to say something positive
about reebok.
Mike lec sponsored by reebok because
reebok classics,
he just stops.
Everything was who'd though fuck is
wearing reebok's these days.
I was,
I was dying dude.
He killed him.
So the hairiest smart dude.
He's a very smart dude.
He's been trying to get me into soccer.
We tried so hard.
You gotta wait,
you gotta wait for fifa.
I mean for the world cup to really get
to.
We tried a few times,
man.
He sits me down.
It's pretty close.
Yeah,
it's pretty close.
It's still going on to catch the wave
one when we were thinking about doing
jamie is we're going to do like a fight
companion,
but uh,
a game companion and have ian and me
come down here.
But I'm going to be for you right now.
I'm going to be so high.
I'm barely going to be able to talk to
me to watch soccer and really appreciate
it and it's letting you know I'm a fan,
but it is a slow sport son for
companion.
Be tom,
be sitting up here with these jumbo
sprays,
the breast ca.
What is that exactly?
Just doing some weird shit.
It's the end of the world.
I took 10 of these accidentally.
Not accidentally.
I did it on purpose.
Thousand milligrams.
thc worries.
No worries.
You can go d spray.
It's legit.
Some gives you shit.
Minty breath and
jump pluto right there.
You'd need that for a second.
Slightly aBove pluto.
It's not a bad idea.
Yeah,
you need it.
You can't really just go out and
natural.
You can't.
You know,
you start freaking out.
Even I would do that for soccer
companion.
You.
Yeah.
That's a long companion and there's
like,
there's not a lot of excitement.
You liked the edibles to go to sleep,
right?
Yeah.
A lot of people like,
well,
you know what?
Not edibles in the vapor pen asleep.
Oh really?
Edibles were giving me a ha.
Like I almost felt like a groggy in the
morning.
Really?
Yeah.
Maybe Just went too deep with what?
Milligram?
Edibles,
retaken.
I don't know.
Not the joey diaz shit.
Nobody.
Just literally just one hit from the
vapor and I'll sleep like a baby.
I cannot shut my mind off.
Joey diaz style once jamie doesn't get
affected by them.
Jamie,
he's got super powers,
get some super resistant,
have terrible superpowers.
Edibles,
and this is not
uncommon because Mike Schmidt,
who's my guest yesterday apparently has
the same issue.
He doesn't edibles,
do not affect him and mike smokes a lot
of weed so maybe that has something to
do with it,
but jamie does not get hot.
But you tried tums.
Someone told you three times and then
gave it like a half hour to try to set
in and then try to 150 milligram cookie.
where'd you get the idea of toms on
twitter?
I've never heard it.
I've asked lots of people at different,
different potheads,
different nutrition.
I think I've even asked rhonda patrick
when she came in one time,
if she had any idea.
We had five minutes to kill.
I figured out she was like,
what?
I know I shut.
She might've just said,
I have no idea.
I don't remember what her answer was,
but I've never heard the tums acid thing
with,
uh,
the 11 hydroxy metabolite.
Yes.
It might have a thing.
That's my dad who's been eating it for a
long time since the sixties,
seventies and debbie and uh,
it's been going deep.
He said jeanette,
to the administration he's got.
He's a hippie guy.
Yeah.
But like his sister,
it'd be my aunt also doesn't have any
reaction to it.
So what a shitty sound.
The genetic thing could be some weird
dna switch that's not honoring.
My mom and my stepdad are in boulder
right now and uh,
you know,
they're retired.
They're doing the world tour that go on
everywhere.
They live in Mexico and they,
uh,
they travel all over the place.
They're,
they're living a beautiful life.
It's retirement.
I love it.
Anyway,
uh,
my,
they made my mom wait in the car because
my mom didn't have her license on her.
She went to a pot store,
they went to a pot store together in
Mexico.
No bolder and bolder and my dad went In
with my mom and my mom had to wait in
the car.
They go pitch,
you got to get out of here.
Really don't have your id.
They're so they're so even though it's
legal,
she's in her fucking sixties.
and they're like,
yeah,
no,
we don't trust you got to running a
tight ship and you never know crazy.
Like you don't have you,
you don't have your id.
So you got to wait in the car ma'am.
She's a grandma.
That is weird.
At 60.
I mean obviously she's over 21,
but I've seen good tonight at like a
liquor store.
I get that.
It's so ridiculous.
It's so fun.
Yeah.
I mean,
unless you have some crazy disease that
makes your grandma,
but even then if you do,
you should let them have their pot and
their booze.
Anyone can they get shut down though?
Like someone came was like,
let me see everyone's ids.
Boy,
I guess.
I mean,
I guess you could,
but you'd have to prove that they
weren't the right age.
You would have to like just be selling
someone under age.
All my mom would have to do is go to a
hotel room and go,
hey,
fucko some 69 years old also.
No.
Cops can be like,
ma'am,
are you sure?
Yeah.
They're going to look at 21.
Yeah,
she's going to go,
whoa.
I didn't know.
Have you been in some of those weed
shops in denver?
It's like the ipad store.
It's awesome.
It's ridiculous.
I'm a big fan of legalization obviously.
Yeah,
obviously I'm Montana where I was just
at.
Apparently they just in august of new
draconian measure kicks in and they're
trying to put the kabash on those
fucking ranchers and cowboys out there.
They're trying to put the kibosh on the,
uh,
the uh,
the pot movement out there.
And what they've done is they've put
like some heavy restrictions on the
amount of people that doctors can
prescribe marijuana to the amount of
people that care givers can prescribe it
to or dispense it to.
Like if you're a caregiver,
you can't.
Just like in a perfect example,
I have a license,
I go to a store that might serve fucking
a thousand people who knows it might
serve more than a thousand.
You go in there and there's just tons of
people all over the place.
Everybody has prescriptions and it
doesn't matter.
But in Montana they're making it pretty
difficult to have a legit reason.
Yeah,
well we're staying.
We were staying at this hotel called the
element in bozeman and right across the
street was this pot shop.
And I was looking.
I was like,
perfect right there.
And then I'm like,
ooh,
I wonder what kind of restrictions they
have.
So then I googled it and like,
oh boy,
it's about to come down on them.
But the thing with Montana didn't denver
set the blueprint like we're getting
rebates,
tax rebates.
Denver's like we have too much moneY.
We cannot store it.
Just give it to the people.
These ranchers,
they don't even read in the newspaper.
They get smoke signals.
They're barely paying attention to
what's going on in the rest of the free
world.
I don't know who's doing it.
I don't know whose.
This is just a lot of people that have
this idea that pot smokers are dumb and
lazy and a problem and they don't
understand.
There's a lot of pot smokers like you
are like me that work hard as fuck and
are just adults and we want to be able
to do whatever the fuck we want to go to
venice beach because that could help you
out.
Help you.
One of those doctors.
I went in there to talk on those doctors
like this is so fucking shading.
Everyone in here is illusory.
Fitzsimmons Was talking to me about the
last time I was in denver.
It's like there's a few too many kids
playing hacky sack on the street.
They have a point.
We can't generalize everybody.
Well,
when you get a place like denver,
the problem is it becomes a magnet to
people that are attracted by
legalization.
A lot of those people are,
they're listless or drifters.
Sure.
Or they're people that are there.
This is going to be the place where I
could be me,
man.
Whereas if it was legal everywhere,
they would stay where they are.
Yeah.
They wouldn't have to go somewhere to
get pot.
So if you feel like you should keep the
natural ecosystem of losers in all their
natural environments,
but when you have one place and it's the
only place where they can get pot and
bitches are all over denver and venice,
there was a way you could give people an
understanding of what motivation and
discipline can reward you with.
Like I reallY did.
What do you mean?
Understanding you don't think social
media,
instagram and seeing you commentate and
stuff like that.
Does that for people?
Um,
maybe.
But I mean some people that are just
like say,
let's put it this way.
Say if you had a kid,
obviously you do have a kid,
but say if you had like a 20 year old
and he's just a fucking doper where a
wakened bakes and doesn't get anything
done.
It's just always like hanging out with
his friends and playing video games and
he's just a fucking loser.
I wish there was a way you could show
someone like that,
like I know that you're getting some
comfort and satisfaction.
I just laying around doing nothing,
eating,
getting fat,
but your life would feel better and
richer.
If you had a goal,
you chase that goal,
you accomplish some things and you would
get this boost of confidence.
You'd get tHis boost of self esteem like
whatever it is that you're going to do,
and maybe you're in a drawing comic
books.
Maybe you're into making fucking pottery
or sculptures or who,
but fine,
whatever the fuck that is,
and pursue that instead of doing nothing
like the people that are doing nothing.
Those are the real pen.
Look,
doing something might be as simple as
that.
Alex honnold guy climbs rocks,
but he's world class rock climber.
It's something but it's also a goal of
his and he's also the best at it.
Yes,
but those.
Those people who smoked pot all day and
do those.
Also,
the guys who hate on joe rogan for being
in shape,
you know what I'm saying,
or being disciplined or get on kevin
harts and scram and hate on,
you know what I'm saying?
Because they don't,
it's their own insecurities.
I see what you're saying.
But I,
I would assume they would get motivated
by seeing other people do something with
their lives.
Like that should be motivating.
Not.
Yeah,
but courage you up if you grew up with
losers and you're around a bunch of
people with shitty attitudes,
especially if it's in your household.
I was very lucky that,
uh,
both my mom and my stepdad there.
No,
they're not.
They're the least hater people I've ever
met my life.
They're just not haters in any way.
Like if someone's doing well,
there was like,
wow,
look at this guy.
Or like,
wow,
look at her.
Or wow,
look at him.
There was never any hate in my house in
terms of other people's success.
But if you grow up with a dad and your
dad's like,
eh,
these fucking all these rich asshole
fucking pussy,
he thinks she's a bad ass.
And tHis bucket,
you know,
there's people that look at other
people's success and instead of saying,
wow,
look,
I did a lot of work,
like the way I'm a successful person,
but the way I look at Kevin Hart,
he exhausts me,
you know,
or the rock.
Those guys have exhausted me.
I'm like jesus christ,
like I feel lazy next to those guys.
Like they do so much.
Like those guys are so overbearingly
ambitious,
you know.
But some people they see that and they
compare themselves and they don't like
it so they could start getting really
shitty and it's like a natural feeling
to try to chip away at that person.
Folk the little Kevin Horn.
Oh,
fucking smack.
I mean this month mother fucking funny.
and you see like the mean nasty shit
that people say to them.
Like,
um,
he went back and forth with some woman
on instagram was saying that his
girlfriend is only with him for his
money.
It was hilarious.
Like Just,
it's amazing that he decided to engage,
but instead is what he was like,
just got done running and it's doing all
that run.
I just bought his shoes by the way.
He has his own shoes,
nike shoes.
I'm like,
I got to support that.
I need a new trainer.
So I bought them jesus.
But uh,
yeah.
So he's not even pull up a picture of
those.
You said I'm a bachelor and jamie got
all excited.
Then
they have like his motivational quotes
on them.
I was like,
I have to support this guy doing this
fucking thing.
But uh,
yeah,
he started out his arm there and he's
like the only reason because it was a
picture of his fiance or something like
that,
like going reason why she's with you
because you're famous and [inaudible]
your money.
Look at that shelf Is wealth women.
That sign is saying,
yeah.
And his dog aspire work,
hustle,
hustle hard.
Oliver shoes see my ass on this kind of
stone work in those things.
They are Kevin Hart shoes like the,
it says hustle hart on the tongue.
That's hilarious.
Inside it says Kevin Hart.
How can you not appreciate that?
I appreciate what he's doing.
I mean all over the fucking choose.
I mean look,
if anybody gets those and it makes them
work a little bit harder and achieve
more success because of that.
Fuck yeah.
Good for them.
Yeah.
I Just poured them.
Let jews doing box jumps and shit.
Look at them.
There is this huge movement,
man.
Any town He goes into,
he does all these five ks and decades
and all that shit.
It's pretty cool.
He's a smart dude,
man.
He's smart.
He's motivated,
he's positive.
You got to have a talk with a mutual
friend of ours where we were talking
about work and I said it's all relative
because we look at you look at a used
you.
I used a,
a bunch of guys who were in the same
field and it's like you look at the
amount of work they're doing compared to
what you're doing and it's just you work
man.
Like I think our definition of work is
completely different because I might
look at joe rogan and say,
right,
he sold out the theater.
He's doing this ufc thing,
but you didn't start there like it's
overwhelming if you look at the huge
picture of the body of work of a guy
who's successful,
but he started just like you did
somewhere,
man.
But people see that and they just get
shut down because too Much of a hill to
climb the.
Yeah.
They look at it in terms of like,
I will never sell out 50,000 people in
philadelphia.
Like Kevin Hart did so fuck this.
Kevin didn't start there.
No.
Kevin started just like you did or
didn't have shit.
Yup.
He is just a guy that is just on fire
with his energy and his just.
His power is just,
he's just got a lot of passion and
drive.
It just goes.
And he also,
he reiterated that work ethic,
reiterated all the time.
I work hard,
you know what I mean?
You go to his twitter account that says
like,
my name's Kevin Hart and I work hard.
Like that's like hashtag shit.
Big,
big part of who he is.
So I think,
you know,
some people just,
they don't understand that,
that if you just keep doing that,
it does pay off and so they just get
overwhelMed and again they start hating,
hating.
Yeah.
And liKe when I was listening to the joe
schilling podcasts use time,
but he just came off that loss.
I meant to reach.
I right.
I,
I text you and I meant to call him,
but he was focused on.
But he.
And he's given that power.
It's like,
joe,
you're doing shit,
man.
Anyone who's doing successful stuff,
even though you lost still on the
baddest man on the planet,
the woodville heckers and the haters,
that stuff,
it comes with the territory man.
If you weren't doing shit,
they're not going to hate on you.
So,
so given them power in acknowledging
that it's Just a bad,
like you're going to deal with that
whether you won or lost man,
he comes with the territory.
YeaH.
It's just one of those things mean he's
a.
Especially because he's as powerful
guys,
wild ass kick boxer who wound up losing.
So it's an opportunity for the losers to
feel like they're more of a winter than
him because they didn't get knocked out.
Yeah.
I meant to reach out to and I forget.
He's fine.
He took it better,
way better than he did the last fight,
the last fight.
He lost the same dude was a lot tougher
for him.
Yeah.
He,
he gave a great point though,
how you're saying like that's his
fighting style.
He likes to go out on a shield.
There's guys like that man.
While he does man,
I mean that is how he fights every
single fight.
He fights like a wild man.
It's this shit.
You know,
he's a,
he's the reason why he's one of the best
in the world.
He's an exciting guy to watch.
I mean,
if you,
if you're looking for a guy to be the
brand name or the,
you know,
the figurehead for your organization for
kickboxing,
you want an exciting guy.
That's your fucking guy,
man.
He's your guy.
Yeah,
he's,
he.
the thing about joe is like,
he's not allowed like flashy guy.
Like he's almost,
he's a quiet,
intRoverted type of dude.
You have a conversation with them,
you know what I'm saying?
Like,
you know,
a lot of ways.
Yeah,
he really is.
He's like a reserved Kevin Ross,
Kevin Ross,
another good example of a,
a great,
really example of a guy who would be a
great,
like,
you know,
I keep saying figurehead,
but like what would be spokesperson or
you know,
an example of a championship caliber
fighter that you would admire,
you know,
and kevin fights very technical.
He's a really interesting guy to watch a
really liked the way you fight.
So like the waY puts combinations
together like very,
very,
uh,
diverse attacks.
he mixes things up and twist things
around on you and varies.
He switches up to speed.
It was attack,
you know,
the thIng with that would have to happen
for bellatore,
but kickbox in general,
especially joe schilling,
they just need to tell a story.
So people are invested because his
story,
it's fucking cool and he's a good guy to
get to know,
but that story's just not getting out
there.
They also have to change the name
valador.
Get out of here with that.
It's not helping enough.
It's not tried it.
You tried it forever.
It's probably holding you back.
You don't think you think you don't
think they're in too deep?
No.
What would you call it?
spike kickboxing.
Spike mma.
But then spike owns your cake.
spike owns it.
Tough shit.
It's by guns.
It already will know.
Build towards a separate item on spike,
but it's just.
It's just mma.
You're going
to have to do something like the ufc
does.
Right?
Like ultimate fighting championship.
Like nfl,
nba,
viacom,
mma.
no,
no.
I just think the name is too dumb.
It's tough.
It's a tough sell.
It's dumb.
Did you like strikeforce?
It's better.
What?
Stripe or it sounds ridiculous.
Strikeforce elites.
So like a jet.
It's silly as combo battalion.
Yeah.
That's a dumb name to your right here.
They all suck.
You have seized the best by far.
The best name.
Ultimate fighting championship.
Dream.
Pride with pride.
Pride was amazing organization,
but if you walk around with a fist that
says pride on it.
Oh,
these days
I used to have a pressure.
I'm like,
I can't wear that anymore.
I didn't know what it's not relevant
anymore.
Well,
I see people with pride shirts on.
I give them fist bumps because your
number may go down west hollywood with a
pride shirt on.
Pride never die in free.
Fucking.
You know what I love most about pride?
I watched it purely as a fan.
I never,
not,
not just most because they had some of
the greatest fights of all time,
but also because I got to enjoy it
purely as a fan.
Never called any of those fights.
Never was there live.
Was an invested really.
You just a super fan of it.
I just got to enjoy it.
Just enjoy it.
Pure and I think that's why we put on a
pedal stool.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's like it's pride.
You weren't like breaking it down and
when it was coming up I was just a
fucking fan.
Yeah.
Had a cro cop show.
I was watching that shit.
Just like enjoying the.
Do you remember watching some of them
live where you'd have to get up at like
fucking 3:00 in the morning?
Fuck that.
Because they were from Japan,
so ridiculous.
And then I remember being at the one in
vegas the first time I ever came here
when favor coleman and I was just blood
the shitty suit on,
on a lazman and a shitty suit on shitty
haircut.
Just like memorize by everyone.
Mesmerize,
not memorized tHem.
Men.
I met saul,
phil baroni and I thought it was fucking
will smith.
right.
And he was a straight dick to me was.
He was,
yeah,
cause my husband,
my buddy a clot and like,
oh let's get a picture of phil baroni.
The New York bad ass was just
ridiculous.
I'm all,
phil,
can I get a pic?
He turns around,
he is a juice to the gills,
like just fucking what?
He's like,
just call me a prick.
Like,
no,
I'm so intimidating.
Like I said,
pick.
He was,
yeah,
let's do it.
Took the pictures and I'm looking at the
camera.
Just checking out some girl.
It's just like this shitty picture.
I watched that dave a fight the other
day when he knocked out dave,
my name.
Oh dude,
what a common nation.
He like,
pinned him up against the cage.
He was unconscious and just keeping them
up with punches and punches.
Just hit them with like four or five
ridiculously hard punches in
a row while he was out standing up.
Phil baroni,
remember when he knocked out of marzullo
of that bad ass russian dude who want to
be in like a hitman.
Oh yeah.
That guy just died from cancer in the
pokey.
In Russia.
No.
Yeah,
but there was some rumor that he was
some hitman that he had a turned to a
life of feeling like,
yeah,
if we russian guy,
we hear that story like remember fate or
his brother.
It was like the tattoo on his back and
grim reaper cause he kills people and
the grim reaper holding a baby the most
intense tattoo of all time.
That was the most intense tattoo.
A grim reaper holding a baby and he had
some russian mob shit that was tattooed
on his chest and shoulders.
Didn't have a tramp stamp.
Yeah.
That's.
Look at that terrible baby books off his
work ever.
That's all russian prison shit.
But he had some shit on his front
shoulders.
That guy's in jail now.
Yeah,
he's in prison,
righT?
Right.
Yeah.
He's in jail.
So those things on his end is.
See those.
He covered up the shit that was there to
make that.
Damion,
but they have those all marked up.
Those numbers,
those numbers that indicated in that
photo.
That's like indicating all the different
tattoos go above far to the left.
The third one right there.
Pat precede that shows that shows like
what he got tattooed.
I guess it doesn't.
That just shows up.
He's got a horse on his chest and he's a
really terrible tattoos,
but he's a
dad bod for that photo shoot.
See?
That's what he used to have.
See those things,
those stars.
Apparently those things have something
to do with the russian mob or organized
crime or something.
So he had them covered over with those
designs.
So that's the original ones there and
now they're those weird.
Let's be some serious shit if you have
to cover him up where pride.
It was like,
yo man,
we got to cover these up.
I don't think pride wanted them to do
it.
I think,
you know,
he probably just reached a turning point
in his life.
He was like,
okay,
but you don't get out though.
Uh,
I don't know.
I mean,
he's in prison.
So what's he in prison for?
Do we know?
I believe it's rape,
but of course,
god,
yeah.
Yeah.
Who knows?
You hear about ryan,
jim hillman.
Fuck and horrible.
But great guy.
He was great guy.
Apparently got hit by a car,
got out to check the damage and whoever
hit him random over.
See,
I heard something else.
Maybe I'm off.
Do you know jay?
I heard he had an altercation inside,
like a bar.
Oh.
Then it continued outside and the dude
was in a monster truck,
like a big,
just a truck lifted.
And jim owned him where he was.
The guy who hit him was in his truck.
Then he backed up and ran over.
Ryan drove off.
Maybe that's true.
I heard,
uh,
you know,
right after it happened or read about it
online.
Uh,
someone I think I saw on twitter,
rip ryan gmo,
and I was like,
no,
no man,
I couldn't believe it.
I went no.
And then then I saw some reports and I
think they probably didn't have all the
data.
Hair goes.
Thirty four year old jim.
I was involved in a verbal altercation
with two suspects before it was hit by
the vehicle to men.
That truck identified as anthony get
shoal and Jordan Wagner immediately fled
the scene soon after,
but were eventually arrested less than a
week after the incident.
There subsequently charged with second
degree murder and accessory after the
fact to the murder respectably.
Want to just propose to her on the way
home from the movies truck began
tailgating them.
I think our storage combined make this
thing.
So we took a left to let them go by.
Now they're both.
Okay.
What's going on?
First?
Reading the parking lot.
No clue where we were at.
These guys pulled up real close behind
ryan almost if they're going to hit us,
both felt nervous.
Why?
And felt the need to do something
because we didn't want them following us
out of there.
I was kind of scary.
Something not right.
Wow.
To talk to.
They were not nice guys.
When I came to get back to philadelphia,
went back,
talked to them after the two men hit
gentleman sped off.
Fuck man.
Jesus christ.
Yeah.
You know what,
man?
People are fucking crazy.
You never know.
You just for whatever reason,
you cut somebody off and they on math
and they just decided to run you over.
She holds no hatred towards the men that
killed jim.
Owen is merely trying to remain positive
through her moments of grief.
Good girl.
Good luck with.
Wow.
That's crazy.
What a shitty situation,
man.
Wow.
Boy,
that's heavy.
You know,
decisions that you make in this life and
that's a big one that people make is
fucking hostility behind the wheel.
But I see it all the time.
I was watching these guys real recently
just screaming and yelling at each other
in their car.
I'm like,
this could easily end up in death and
get the fuck out of here.
These,
these guys could easily get out and
shoot each other or me,
I just assumed they have guns,
so which might be a weird way to look at
it.
It's a safe way.
Like literally last night we were
driving through venice,
July 4th,
the light turned yellow,
you know,
it's busy.
So like I'm in the way of them going the
other way and this dude just like move
out the fucking idiot and the people in
the car you might go like,
like,
what do you want me to do?
You want me to yell back at him for
what?
I don't give a fuck.
He's like,
who cares?
Who cares man?
You never know.
I mean,
it's not hard to get a gun.
It's definitely not hard to get a gun
here in los angeles.
Plus if it's a little guy barking this,
you know,
there's a reason.
Why is that confidence?
Well usually they're just stupid,
but it's possible that he has a gun too.
But all the to things like what we're
talking about.
But the difference between,
you know,
being in a community where there's less
people and people value people versus
being in,
you know,
but then again,
jimmo lives up in edmonton.
That's not a crowded place in edmonton
is a city to big city is a pretty good
amount of people up there,
but it's not like los angeles.
Sure.
But you know how people,
a lot of people are drunk and they're
doing drugs and there's all sorts of
shit going on.
It's clouding your judgment.
It's just sad.
That's a bummer.
Yeah.
He was a good guy too.
Really good guy.
Very,
very friendly gun fighter to watch too.
Yeah.
I think burt watson was the one who
wrote rip.
Jimmo is looking at birth because I
follow bird on twitter.
Really?
What's doing.
Just to switch it up.
He's doing what he used to do with some
other organizations.
Oh,
is he still doing that?
Yeah.
That's a guy I miss.
I miss that dude,
bro.
Was the man.
Yeah.
Lay still is the man.
He's just the man somewhere else other
than the ufc.
True.
But you don't see him anymore.
Did do a stitch is back right?
I think so in the ufc,
right?
Am I going crazy?
I saw him at that belt or meeting them
at a great combo and he said he's back
in the ufc.
I thought I saw him.
That would be nice if he wanted like
show me fight.
That could have been bellatore ufc,
but whatever reason he wasn't.
The eoc was ridiculous.
He criticized the reebok deal just like
we just did
and I'm out of the ufc.
What are you going to do?
What are you gonna do?
I don't have a stake in the game
anymore.
We're out of time here.
It's 4:30 already,
dan.
That's fast son.
We just through,
but we actually talked about the fights
though.
We did.
People don't think we're going to.
It started off.
We started off a little shaky.
Well,
you got me rattled before with the stuff
that you're telling me before we
started,
I started out.
I got dumped on simon and we ended.
We ended with gmo will rest in peace.
Ryan.
Jim.
Oh,
you were great man.
Life goes on as hard.
I was going to promote a live show.
You just can not do it.
Promote it.
When is it a fire in the kid?
Live in phoenix,
Arizona.
You're going to get brian calendar.
July 29th and 30th.
Brian might be there.
He's going to be there.
He'll be there.
Slap them that you guys do in phoenix
live.
Yeah.
La,
la,
whatever it is.
Yeah.
That's great.
Is it good job?
Oh yeah man.
It's been shown on the 29th one show on
the 30th.
Beautiful t dot k dot curious.
Uh,
tomorrow night I'm at the ice house with
greg fitzsimmons,
tony hinchcliffe,
a duncan trussell and ian edwards.
Whoa.
Damn.
And then friday night I'm at the cop
theater at the mgm with ian edwards and
joey motherfucking is so,
uh,
and we'll be back tomorrow with milo
yiannopoulos.
So until then,
fuck yourself.